Like fucking robbed. And now look at
that. Um, live. Ladies and gentlemen,
we are alive. We are here at the
compound, chillin with Eddie the twister.
Bravo Shizam son. Welcome to
the podcast again, Mr Ravo, sir,
thank you for having me, man.
Thank you for being, it's,
it's an honor to be on the show sponsored
as always by the fleshlight and you
know, dudes giving me shit
about promoting this. And uh,
lately guys like woody was spokesman
from the flashlight while he was bring up
the flourish. Let your
podcast, first of all,
because the fleshlight is
actually sponsoring this pocket,
that fucking thing behind me. I forgot
how. Shut that off, man. First of all,
we never,
we never have something that doesn't fuck.
Only twice we've ever done this where
we don't have sound going off in the
background. My computer has the, um, the
volume on, oh, my cat's in the room too.
That's also could be a mistake.
Yeah, I thought I kicked her out.
She's so needy.
She's an awesome cat,
but she's needy as fuck
when it comes to a podcasts.
She doesn't give a shit about you
guys. Spazz go, go, go, go as fast.
Was that you or the cat? That was
fine. It was probably a cat. Anyway,
people have been giving me a hard time
saying like what are you a spokesperson
for the Po?
For the flashlight?
No I am not but they are sponsoring this
podcast and I'm here to tell you just
as a person who jerks off,
it's a fucking solid product.
It doesn't seem like it would be. It
seems like it's a silly thing. It's the,
but look,
you're going to jerk off.
Just accept that and it's like 50 bucks
or something like that and I think it's
like 15% off, 69 bucks, 69 bucks
and there was some of them vibrate.
They cross more. You don't need
that. What do you, a fucking robot.
The vibration probably would
not be the best on that day.
How much distance in a that would work.
It's just a dude who buys like extras
who will want it loaded. Loaded.
It's like in the 60 60
bucks and it's like 50% off.
So for like 70% off for other,
for like another 15 bucks for the wig.
You're talking about 75 bucks total.
Well,
Brian's been stuff in them and
couches and fucking them. Yeah.
You put them in between the two.
I did that with a towel once
you take a a plastic bag, uh,
a friend of mine, we both know
him. Uh, he's a cartoonist. Oh,
tell that you get a plan.
You put a towel out and then you put a
plastic bag on it and then you roll up
the towel, right. And then it's
like a Burrito and then you make,
you just put some,
you know,
some guy has a youtube tutorial on
how to make your own fleshlight.
He makes it really, yeah, it looks
super complicated. But the bottom line,
that's like, how much time is
your time worth? An hour. Okay.
Is it worth 20 bucks an hour?
It's going to take you more
than three hours to make
that gut. Just buy it. Right?
You don't want to be cool.
You know,
it'd be awesome if you were so tight and
so cool with your housekeeper that you
didn't even have to clean it. You can just
leave it out by like 20 of them. Right.
You buy like 20 of them and then she
cleans for you. Right. That would be dope.
Then I would use that
shit all the goddamn time.
Me and my housekeeper just saying we
ain't that tight yet. Yeah, that, no,
no housekeeper wants to be cleaning loads.
That's where they draw
the line. How cool would it be? Seriously.
That would be cool if you could
just throw it like underwear.
You know when you just
leave your shit everywhere.
You know your housekeepers coming
on Wednesday. You know what I mean?
It'd be cool, man. Then I would definitely
use it. I buy it wholesale and shit.
That's like, somebody told
me the other day, it's like,
don't you know that we'd stores or like
a way for the government to get involved
and take your money. I'm like, dude, I
can use a credit card and be in and out.
You know? That's why. Who cares if
the government gets a piece of it.
Who the fuck told you the government's
involved in the West because of credit
card?
Well that is the number one problem with
hanging out with people that smoke pot.
Is there so many dopey stoners
that have like crazy ideas?
The latest is that this Gulf
disaster is um, all the,
the wacky are saying that this was a
planned event and that they're doing this
to use it as an excuse to kill off a
giant percentage of the population.
Is Alex Shelan saying that too?
He said we need to get to them.
We need to get to the bottom of it.
He's got to have black helicopters.
Ladies and gentlemen.
What they're doing right now in the Gulf
mirrors what they're trying to do in
our school systems. They're
trying to take your guns. Did,
if you ever had a cartoon,
you would have to have the Alex Jones
be a character in the Joey d is because
those two are almost perfect,
like identical.
You could totally have the best
I can do Alex. Really good.
If I listen to them when I listened
to him, ladies and gentlemen,
I get the tones of the voice.
I understand what the new world
order is plotting and it's evil.
It's wrong.
What is they're coming for your babies.
They want to put implants in your uterus.
What does Joey think about the oil spill?
What the fuck are you bothering me
with this oil spill bullshit. Listen,
cock sucker.
I got no time.
I've got 10 cats and the weed store is
open at 9:00 AM. You know what I'm saying?
I get down there. I get my
old g Kush. I say, hello.
Maybe I have some fresh squeezed orange
juice and I mind my fucking business.
This was asked, this was asked on my
form of spring that I just started.
Cannabis clubs are one of the biggest
capitalist money making schemes that have
ever come around in 15 years. Why is
this never called out? Why is that? Well,
what does that mean? Capitalist money
making schemes. Okay. First of all,
the one that I go to that
Joe was just shut down.
What's shut was owned by
a guy who's a businessman,
who's a nice guy who took a chance on
something that's very controversial,
like opening up a marijuana store and he
provides good service and he has loyal
customers because he's a friendly guy
and they always give you like free joints
and everything. When you leave here,
try these cookies, they're awesome.
They're super nice and super friendly.
And it was a privately owned business
by one guy. This guy's full of shit. I,
this guy was providing me
with an awesome service.
He was selling great.
We'd all legally doing
everything according to
California state law by the book,
every single aspect of it.
And he had a nice business going.
We're at a bunch of people
that were like loyal business.
There's nothing that government has
nothing to do with that. I mean,
no more than the government has to do
with me telling jokes because look,
if I'm telling jokes, you know,
if I'm getting paid to do comedy,
I got to pay taxes.
So when a sense when you go to see my
act support the government, you know,
I mean really in a sense,
you know,
I pay the government a ton of money
every year it comes 48% or something like
that of your,
your money.
It goes literally to taxes supporting my
government by drinking is coconut water.
Yeah. Well he's launching a certain
amount of fucking government folks. Okay.
Don't worry about, you know where the
money from pot stores is going. All right.
Worry about the massive impact that
marijuana being that accessible and
basically legal, the massive impact
that that has on our culture.
It's only been going on for a few years
and I've noticed a giant difference in
just how many people are more aware.
How many more people are, are just
like aware of like the legality of it.
Why, why it's illegal, what
the, you know what the,
the whole conspiracy was with William
Randolph Hearst back in the 30s.
So many more people are informed
and people aren't afraid of anymore.
It's not like people think that
it's going to give you brain damage.
Just going to fuck your world up.
Like people understand now that that's
bullshit and they're starting to realize
that it can enhance your life.
That's so fucking important, man.
Fuck all this government conspiracy.
The biggest capital is making scheme.
Everyone don't look at that.
Stop. You're being silly.
You're looking for a negative
in something that's incredible.
Marijuana's finally broken through
and I can tell you from California,
it's crazy. You can go anywhere.
There's weed stores. My,
my place got closed down because
it's too close to a school,
but I put an article on my, uh, on
Twitter and I put an article or you know,
I put a post on Twitter and I put
a post on a message board, hey,
where are the good places in the
valley in California and fucking,
I got dozens of suggestions.
Like instantly that's,
there's never been a time like this
ever. I like my place. Check it out.
It's just a house.
It's like a suburban neighborhood.
What's your face going to
Luca? Late collective. Oh,
you took me there once. Yeah.
That place is cool. Yeah, no, that
place is very good. It is like a house,
like you go in little little picket fence,
front yard and shit was kind of weird.
The Best Shit is med pot delivery.com
have you ever thought that? I done,
I've already used them. Now
what's the negative? My mother,
I needed weed and this
motherfucker came to my house.
The negatives is that illegal?
The negatives and some dude who delivers
pot knows where you live? No. No.
Oh, okay. You actually bought weed from
him before. Which guys? His name is Brett.
He trains that.
I'm in Culver city with a Gerson.
He's a bog Gracie guy. We know him. Okay.
You remember that guy? Yeah. Really good.
So now the Shit Med
pot. Oh Dude. But yeah,
that is correct.
Like if you were thinking like out
of this cloud you would say, Hey,
this guy is in the drug business and
he's in my house checking my shit out.
You know, that's Kinda, you
could look at it that way,
but would you be bothered if a guy
came over with a delivery of fine wine?
You wouldn't [inaudible] guy came over
your house and he had some really nice
expensive French wine.
That guy's a drug dealer.
Well I would never let
him in my house like,
like I don't let me pee he ups guy
but I would have to let them eat that.
The weed guy in my house.
Cause you're
not going to just break out.
No.
You would know why not if it's legal
because I have my neighbors don't care if
it's legal. They think, oh this guy's
doing drugs on the front porch neighbors.
My neighbors can suck my Dick
Button from your neighbor.
You could roll down the hill and you
still don't hit your neighbors. Yeah,
but if I did,
even if I did have neighbors,
your neighbors should do
who the fuck you are, man.
You worried about getting a bag of weed
and from your neighbors. That's crazy.
Yeah.
Well they also own the place.
So I think if a guy came over your
house and deliver a nice case won,
you'd let them right in.
You let them run it in a role that
little dolly right into your kitchen like
dumb.
Fuck some wine.
I lost my fucking button up shirt.
It's trust me. It's hilarious.
I just met with someone
with that mentality.
I mean once a drug is a drug,
it's responsible for so
much art and culture and so
much of the way human beings
behave. You know, alcohol based societies,
any alcohol based society, they're there.
It's like, you know when
societies getting into alcohol,
it's always like violence and yelling and
lots of fun and passion and poetry and
music and shit like that. Next weed
and alcohol together. That's the past.
Isn't it funny though that you'd never
think of wine as a drug but nobody thinks
of why like I do drugs. What kind
of drug you do? I do. One was,
this certificate is not to be trusted.
I don't know what that's going on.
I think my Twitter is crashing. My girl,
ex girlfriend used to always say that.
She's always said that wines, that
drug, that a certificate, nevermind.
Oh there's nobody knows what
we're talking about here.
Twitter is going to be there.
It's going nutty and I'm going
to just going to shut it off.
Shut off the youth stream though. No,
no, no. I'm not shut off shut anyway. Um,
wine is a drug. It really is.
Nobody thinks about, always
forget that, that, that,
that alcohol is a drug and everybody,
especially with walnut time,
wine seems like something, you know, you
have, if you're sophisticated, you know,
it's like the most, the most accepted.
Like if you tell people you smoke weed,
there's a lot of people that look at
you like there's something wrong with,
you don't want to read that shit
sometimes. But then you get like,
you get like wine in a box
and that's just like, man,
this is like cool laid for alcohol. Did
you know $5 I got a whole box of alcohol.
Thank you though. There's nothing worse
than some shitty wine, man. I agree.
What do you think Mel Gibson was
drinking when he made those calls?
What was he drank? Can
we hear him? If we don't,
if you don't know what
we're talking about.
Mel Gibson apparently lost
his fucking marbles. He's
got this chick who, uh, he's,
uh, I mean he was married for a
number of years and has, uh, you know,
quite a few kids with
and he left her and uh,
this is the new chick
that he hooked up with.
I think it's more than alcohol though.
I think this is just straight like what
she was saying. Crazy person. Yeah.
But you would know. This is what
I've always told people about actors,
like actors are really annoying.
And one of the things that's so annoying
about them is they really are like you,
you, you have to be crazy
to want to be an actor.
You have to be crazy to get
through all those hoops.
And there's a lot of them that are cool.
I'm in a lot of actors that are
really fun to hang around with,
but for the most part, a giant
percentage of them are fucking completely
insane.
And the business coddles to them because
the business has kindly like kind of,
uh,
they're,
they're like always like getting them
food and kissing their ass and Mr. Gibson
will be ready for you in 20 minutes and
he's making so much money and he's the,
you know, the focus of all these people's
attention and love and adulation.
These movies are giant, you know,
passion that Christ is giant.
And so that just blows your fucking ego
up even more, you know? And most of them,
like a good percentage of them
are really truly insane. You know,
a good percentage of actors are,
they're totally delusional.
But we're starting to see that now
because of these, all of these sources,
these TMZ places and stuff like that,
we get to see someone's true personality.
They catch them draw coming out of a
nightclub and you get a camera on him.
All this shit that's going on right now
when you're getting to see like deep
behind the curtain Twitter, I mean,
shit, you know, you got some time.
There's a lot crazy ass celebrities,
I swear to God and couple of fighters.
Oh man, that there, it's growing
machine has an awesome tour falling,
falling apart in front of the world.
You know, it's, it's incredible.
So I'm a loving, very entertaining. Yeah,
there's definitely people that
are losing their fucking shit.
There's a lot of people out there
doing Twitter that really should not be
allowed to talk. You shouldn't be allowed
to be just talking publicly. Yeah.
Handle you man. Like whoever, whoever's
handling Brittany Spears right now,
they've got it wired for years.
This wasn't an issue.
People are going to have publicists
and he could say stupid shit and,
and you know, and nobody, nobody cared.
Nobody ever found out about it all.
Think about all the crazy scandals that
have happened throughout history and how
much they would be much more in
the news today than ever before.
And we'll think about the rod Stewart
pumping the stomach rumor level that,
that was like early eighties when we
talked about this before. The Jabil rumor,
the Richard Gere Djerba rumor.
That's the world champ before Twitter,
before the Internet, he imagined that
shit. That is the world champion rumor.
No rumor can fuck with that.
Richard Greer durable up the ass for
or cause there was nothing, nothing.
There was no CD television shows and
talked about it. There was no internet.
It's somehow or another made it. He grew
up in California. I grew up in Boston.
We both heard it. Yep. That one and that
stomach pumping rod Stewart, Taco Bell's,
uh, survived the sour cream come
rumor. And I still even wild.
I've never even heard this guy
got busted working at Taco Bell.
He just came in a bunch of Tacos. He used
to do it for two months, blah, blah, blah.
It's dry. And that was a rumor only in
your town. That shit didn't make it.
That happens.
That's like portal is food.
We're talking about a human beings.
Life is ruined.
I don't put human beings in my mouth
unless I could stop eating tacos and you
wouldn't have to worry about that guy.
You don't stop being Richard Gere.
What are the two? What are the biggest,
what are the two biggest rumors?
Pre Internet having common loads and sex.
Gay Sex.
[inaudible]
I don't give a fuck what anybody
says. What about the George? Michael.
Remember the George Michael Thing?
Was that before the Internet?
What was that same with with the cops.
I mean there was a boy who was a
meager intern. There was a little,
it was not the kind of culture.
That's how everybody had an AOL.
You know my space. Yeah.
It wasn't like that was,
I watched careless whisper today on
Youtube. George Michael, careless whisper,
do it click.
I think you'll open that shit up.
You went to first year this Mel Gibson,
careless whisper. First they were little.
Mel Gibson. Let's go. Let's go
positive first. That negative
careless whispers, George Michaels
and it's all talking about the videos.
Him and he's dancing.
He's with a girl,
so I'll talk about him and a
girl breaking out. It's a great,
but there's a scene where he has to kiss
the girl. Why did you want it today? Why?
Because it's fascinating.
Was this during fleshlight time,
you're like Sumit on his face,
like with some crazy FBI.
CIA stopped and you see
right when he kept his eyes,
his eyes rolled back, but
it's just something about
the, even the words were gay.
It wasn't just gay, the way he
dressed and looked and you know,
maybe he did it except it guilty feed.
I've got no rhythm.
No, I'm never gonna dance again.
Guilty feed have got no rhythm.
What heterosexual man would be
willing to say that I've done
guilty feet.
I've got no rhythm.
Jyoti feed of what the fuck are you
talking? Oh you got it hooked up Brian
to the soundboard on the fly. Like
write news and gentlemen, tech support.
Extraordinary Brian Redman
Reichle and everything about him.
He's so like feminine, like beautiful,
handsome man. His hair is fabulous.
You know,
striking features only.
Only gay people like saxophone and songs.
If George Michael was strange,
he could do so much damage.
If he says straight aggressive man with
those looks and the fucking voice to the
ads, you know what kind of damage that
motherfucker could have done. Facial hair,
God, everything. The whole
package. Beautiful Man,
sad.
Listen to this
guilty feed.
I've gotten over the cut son.
You're gay and you're
white, gay, guilty feet.
You've got no rhythm.
Fantastic music of the 80s all right.
Now that's positive and that's all good.
And now what we have to talk
about ladies and gentleman,
something that's not so
positive and not so good.
We've got to play this buck and Mel Gibson
clip. Can you cause you need to know,
tell me when to positive
if this was a gay thing,
like a gay relationship. That's
the next, that's the next one.
Going to be a Ted Haggard. Ted Haggard
banned me from fucking Twitter man.
God dammit. What? He
blocked me. I'm so mad.
I want to see you are about all
the time I was enjoying it and uh,
no it was because of a comment.
I think he probably has heard my bit
before but he probably didn't know it was
following them. I mean I would
assume if he's got, if he's online,
someone probably sat on my bed but he's
um, anyway, he wrote on his Twitter,
he goes after Sunday, you know, um,
Bible study sandwiches and
then.dot, dot. Question Mark.
So I wrote math and blow jobs.
Question Mark, my response.
And so he blocked me and fucking very
upset man. Cause it was fascinating.
Reading is Twitter now. I have to, I
could still watch read it though, Dude,
you can't totally block me.
I'll just go in through a web browser.
The old block c on your iPhone though
doesn't it only blocks you on whatever
application using tweetdeck
or Twitter or whatever.
It doesn't do it on the weapon.
He could go right to the website.
Remember that was how our
friend did not know that.
We knew that he was saying some fucked
up shit. Right. Totally unrelated thing.
But,
but so I still get to read and take
into goodness that is the Ted Haggard
Twitter.
If you don't know Ted Haggard,
his famous evangelist that turned out
was actually smoking math and having gay
sex with hookers, all these gay
hookers. And he was like a huge,
like I'm a spokesperson
for the religious right.
Used to have conference calls
weekly with George Bush,
what they would talk about, you
know, such things as, you know,
promoting Christianity and stopping the
gauge. And then it was just a crazy homo.
That sounds like a sitcom.
Like that dude's life is a sitcom.
He's married, he's got kids. He's,
but he's not gay, but he said cooker
on the side just to pay the bills.
Oh my.
And Ted Haggard is one of his customers.
When that got busted,
what did he feel like?
How did that feel to get caught?
Like with the
video taped it like real clear quality,
hello job. That's probably what he
wanted to know. Wanted to get high.
That's probably what this whole thing was.
I mean,
he probably got caught and start twisting
his nipples by what's happening in the
cops know that.
Yeah, he probably, I think Eddie's
right, but I also think that when you,
when you're hiding that much,
I think the pressure is so hard that
you almost want to get caught to end it.
I think the pressure of like
having that big of a secret,
you're this Christian
religious evangelists,
that's like a public speaker
who's revered by the,
the Christian movement and meanwhile
you're smoking crystal meth and sucking a
guy's ass hole. You know, you're, you're
following. I know that. Yeah, no, no.
The guy was very explicit.
Not all guys suck ass or no.
The hooker and the hooker was very,
very open about it.
He talked about the rectum.
They get freaky. I don't know.
I don't remember. I might be
talking about my ass right there.
I don't remember the exact details.
I remember he was talking
about having gay sex.
There's stuff he actually mentioned
sucking blame checks and who don't really
like to suck.
Dick.
I wonder if there's like a lame gay
dudes who they don't really like to look
assholes and I'm sure.
Just give me a little selfish
hope as gay dude. I was on some
mate. Your flicks last night.com.
It's just like youtube for porn.
And there
was this one video where this hot chick
had this nasty boyfriend and she was
just like, this is home amateur video.
Just fucking eating his ass. I want to,
you know, it's like, it's like crazy.
Like how do you get to that point where
you're like, dude, it's right there.
Never had a chick flick your ass, Huh?
Yeah. But it was by mistake kind of.
It wasn't like
Shit's going to lick your ass.
You, you can't, there was a
very funny episode of sex.
She came out that very funny episode of
Sex and the city where a guy wanted to
get his ass lick and he was like,
when he licked her ass and he was
like trying to like lean his, her,
his ass towards her face.
And I like it.
Yeah. I don't know what, what do you,
why do you think porn is going in such
a crazy direction or people spiral
spiraling out of control?
I mean the amount of like fucked up porn,
it's available today. It must
be like 10,000 times. What?
It wasn't the eighties
more even there was,
it was very hard like in the 1980s to get,
I think it's just technology.
They got one mouth fucks,
you know like smacks,
beaten chick checks up and nothing in
their eyeballs and there's like so much
nutty shit that's online like
aggressive, like violent porn. Yeah.
So much more.
It's more people have cameras and
internet connections and what that,
what it is and I think people are numb
to the regular shit and things like porn
and the obsession with porn
accelerates just like technology.
It just gets crazier
and crazier and crazier.
Crazier because there's a lot of like
porn that you used to watch when you were
a kid that you know wouldn't even get
you excited. Now it'd be boring as fuck.
You just get so desensitized. You want
that high resolution closeup. Shit.
1,008 did porn and three d. What's
the latest on that? Who knows? I know,
but you went here. Mel Glitzy. Yeah. Let's
go to Mel Gibson before we go into porn.
All right, here's the, here's the
big call. This is the first one.
This is I think the second one,
but this is like if you don't know Mel
Gibson has this check and the check is is
a baby mamma and she's got his daughter
and so Mel Gibson is calling her and
they're having a
conversation over the phone.
The chicken is secretly taping it and
it's fucking crazy. All right, here we go.
Okay.
Don't hang up on me.
You gotta make this much louder,
Brian. This is really low. All right.
I don't know if this
is going to work folks.
You know when it was better than that,
it was better when you had the microphone
and you put it right over the youtube
again.
We're going to try a different way folks,
cause I think this recording
is just a little too low.
I don't think it's good to the mic. That's
the way we did it before. It's louder.
That's the thing. Give us one
second here, ladies and gentlemen,
we apologize for the delay,
but
you got to Brian.
Yeah, now it's just downloading the video.
It's, I mean it's gonna take a second.
Yeah. To about bringing a
little bit, a lot of it.
Why did it stop Goddamn Internet.
Okay. Right. When you think you've got
to figure it out. Don't hang out with me.
I have plenty of energy to drive
over there. You understand me?
So just listen to me.
Listen to like,
I didn't do anything to you.
You are ruining my life.
Fucking difficult. Well, you know what?
It's your supports me
instead of chuck taught me,
I just fucking sucked me dry.
What
do love me?
What am I?
Oh shit
relationship.
Listen to me as somebody
who loves does not behave.
I know like this because I know
everyone says that you cannot let me and
every time no consideration to
reject it or be happy. Fuck.
Get the fuck away from me,
but my daughter.
That's nice.
I'll get you one more time.
Damn.
You care about that yourself.
I did not do anything.
This is your selfish imagination.
That's okay.
I'm sleeping with the baby.
I'm waking up every two hours.
I still asleep because I was waiting for
you because you weren't ready to go to
Jacuzzi as we reach.
Yup. We agreed. Agreed.
You just fucking expect shit go.
I thought it got down to commit
to yourself to go with you
because
I
left my wife because we had
no spiritual common ground.
Okay.
No fucking dude,
because you heard me so bad.
I didn't want to see normally whether
it be you didn't go do anything.
Oh really?
I want it to peace.
I want it to happen.
No. For me, I didn't.
I feel that bad and be patronized by
dishonesty and meditation.
Medicaid, no god, but
God damn life,
miserable
medication
sampling.
Fuck a little girl with,
I'm fucking dysfunctional
fucking side of the head,
right.
Judy does Dr
Brain transplant.
Fucking
I need medication
because I fucking bend over backwards
with eye balls of and not just do it all
for it. She gives me like I'm
fucking sour. Look or say,
hold on.
You know care about me.
I have no hard time,
bitch.
You fucking bitch.
Don't hang up on me.
Listen to this anymore.
Hang up coming over there.
You fucking, I'm coming to
my house. My house. Honey.
Yes, but you honey. Don't call me honey.
You just
call the police and tell them there.
How about that?
You can do that.
That's fine.
Fuck you.
I don't blog.
I wrote by the policeman anything
because I stand up for myself. Yo,
your week you'll call a fucking cop
and that will go to Lsu is right.
Well don't you fuck off.
Did I
fucking making eyes at me in five seconds.
Five seconds.
She's not your brand,
your fucking friend who took me.
How would he friends?
Come on.
That's fucking actors.
This is what I'm talking about.
When I first moved to California and
I first started working with actors,
I couldn't believe how
crazy so many of them were.
There's a lot of crazy motherfuckers
that just know how to act normal when
they're being interviewed during
press junkets and you know,
and I figured out a way he can save his
career. The black shut the fuck up. No,
no seriously. That is all viral videos
for a movie coming out. It'd be brilliant.
It would be brow crazy viral
video for a movie about a,
an obsessive rich guy who's taking
care of a Russian whore and we mean,
I mean it's going to get worse.
Yeah,
that's a great idea for a movie that's
going to get worse comes over. She,
that's actually a great idea for a movie.
You get a girl from a country like Russia,
which you know, it's poor and they,
they, there's a lot of women over
there that are fucking beautiful man.
Stunningly beautiful. But we
got like a hardness to them,
right? So she comes over,
she decides, all right, I'm going
to let this rich guy, fuck me.
I'm going to make a ton of money and just,
you know,
just deal with it and deal with him
and he just becomes fucking crazy.
And He's like a giant
movie star like Mel Gibson.
You know what movie was kind of like that?
That hasn't even come out yet.
Remember without dude. What
was that? Joaquin Phoenix.
I started growing the beard and going
crazy and then I keep, that's a movie.
Is He doing that for movies? Viral
bullshit. That's what I've always thought.
I was wondered what the other day
did he go on Conan?
Is he like gave up acting east and
then he had all these like television
appearances where he
acted crazy and stuff.
That was like a film I just found out
recently and I thought that from day one
I'm like, this is bullshit. That is not,
why is he on Conan if he's going crazy and
quitting acting, you know? Right, right,
right. That's fascinating. So hopefully
Mel Gibson who was supposed to come out,
I don't know. I just a couple of weeks
ago I heard about it. It was like,
like a document mockumentary there's a
few dudes that can just act their fucking
ass off. There's, you know,
there's a few dudes where I
really appreciate the craft
and what they're doing.
Like a Gary Oldman. He's one of them.
Walk Jakeem. How, how'd you say it?
[inaudible] he's one of them to that
motherfucking could act as ass off.
He did Johnny Cash. Perfect.
Perfect. That's a flux.
Blueray must blueberry. It must be. I
got it on my Mel Gibson. A great actor.
Fuck you. Fuck you. Because he's
crazy as fuck. Back in the day, dude.
The Mad Max days.
Who the fuck would have been a better
mad max and [inaudible] fuck you in the
drive Thru to Mad Max was,
that's a fucking Joe Pesci Bro.
Yeah, but that was from lethal
weapon. The weapon sucked, Dude. I,
that's how I liked the weapon in life.
Horn was okay.
One was kind of cool and then they got
stupid, but mad max is the shit dude.
Mad Max is that, it was
awesome. Bad Ass Braveheart.
Braveheart was the shit. Braveheart was
outstanding. That was his best word. Yeah.
I remember leaving that was like a three
hour movie and I left and I went to the
comedy store right afterwards
and I got on stage and I just,
I had so much fucking energy just from
that movie. Like I felt it like it,
you know, who used to always say that Paul
Mooney, he used to always say that, uh,
whenever he entertains or
whenever he gets entertained,
rather he does a better job
of entertaining. He goes,
I always do a better job after I've seen
something entertaining. Yeah. Braveheart.
I did not expect that.
I thought that was,
I didn't even want to
say it was three hours.
I like the movie I wanted to see wasn't,
it was sold out and I was like,
fuck this Braveheart bullshit.
I walked out of that motherfucker
and my head just exploded.
I thought it was a date movie.
You know, it's like, what
does it mean? What is this?
You know, a bunch of dummies
running on each other with swords.
I always thought that that is like the
most tired premise ever threw his group
of fucking enemy on one side.
You know,
group of soldiers on one side and their
enemy on the other side and they were
run out of each other and fucking smash
in the middle and kill each other.
How many times did they do that
fucking scene and you know, keep going.
Brave heart. Brave heart should be
that should have settled it. That shit.
Unless you're using monsters and goblins
and shit coming at each other like that.
Stop doing that. Stop doing those.
Gladiator was good though too.
People started making more titanics
you know people rip off movies.
There's like a vampire genre.
What if there's a giant cruise
liners sinking genre? Yeah,
they do rip off shore earners but some
they can decide and adventures like the,
that's like the only other, well I think
shit really ripping off. Right, right,
right. But how does that work? There's
only one person authorized. I mean,
anyone can pretty much write their
own story about the titanic, right?
I guess once it's covered
like that and people go, well,
it's a academy award winner.
Let's just leave it alone.
I don't think that they left it alone.
I think there's a lot of
titanic movies called Titanic.
You know there's a couple of shitty
ones you see now like to cheap ones that
existed before. I don't know who
gives a fuck. Who Cares? Yeah,
but anyway, that y'all walking peanuts,
dude. That guy can act as ass off.
There's a few guys like that.
What's his face to the Australian dude?
What the fuck's his name?
Russell Crowe. Correct?
He's a bad motherfucker to Robin Hudson.
Big Balls.
Thought he didn't see that new
one. Yes. I didn't even know.
It looks so fucking guard.
First of all,
he does not look like a Robin Hood.
He's got this fat face.
He looks like a guy who eats too much.
You know what I'm saying? I mean,
he looks like this, like he looks
like a well fed taken care of guy.
He doesn't look like a hungry. It was
in Andrews. Who is Robin Russell Crowe.
Russell Crowe. Like he looked, I
mean he's not fat, but he's not,
he's not like a lean like
sinewy we looking dude,
you know that's what you would
picture of Robin Hood Man.
You don't picture of some guy looks
like well fed and tights and shit.
It's like Robin Hood is that we're trying
to keep out to try to do, if you got,
if Sony pictures gave you like full full
like greenlight power to produce and
direct Jack and you know what I mean?
You go fuck, they gotta go up a hill.
Why do they go up this fucking hill?
You know what I mean? They get
some water. Can you imagine that?
It's like Robin Hood, you, you're,
you're like handcuffed. You got it.
You got this dude in fucking steels.
Like how are we going to make this happen?
I don't see Jack and Jill.
I can see jack and Jill coming out
like the journey up the hill, you know,
or something like that.
I can see a good Robin hood,
but she would have to get someone who's,
you know,
it's all about who writes the
script and who directs it and who,
whose vision it is. Dude did exist
for real, but I mean the story.
Robin Robin Hood. What is the actual
story? It was robbing from the rich,
stealing, robbing the rich and giving to
the poor. That's the whole Robin Hood.
Damn, there's no Robin
went. It's around a day.
Which is the last motherfucker like
what was the, um, what was the story?
It was jeans or something like
that because it was so bad.
I don't remember shit. The
movie was that bad. It was bad.
I liked when he was a fox. He was
a fox. Disney. Who? Russell Crowe.
Robin Hood.
What the fuck are you talking about?
I haven't had the old Disney
cartoon where he's a Fox. What?
The original Robin Hood.
I have no idea what you're talking.
I've never seen Robin had
cartoon movie. No, he was a fox.
Fox Fox who's got some rumors
about loads and Taco bell.
Swear to God. Mushrooms too. Fucking
Fox. Some people can't handle folks.
You know what happened?
We did smoke a lot.
Both we both smoked two
hits each and then I said,
do you want some more and Brunch
it? No, no, no. Mother fucker.
What are you talking about? I
said, God Damn Fox. Listen Brian,
just because remember this? No,
I don't. No, I don't. I don't.
That's, that's like a classic Disney
movie like Bambi and stuff. No,
not everyone saw that.
So he was a fox first came Robinhood.
I don't remember
Ryan.
I when I was talking to some or something.
Well, okay. Anyway, the point was the
Russell Crowe's movie wasn't very good.
Back to fucking Mel Gibson. Holy
Shit. When he said, when he,
he tried to break up
his friendship with the,
her friendship with their best friend
that she sucked me in five seconds.
She's not your friend.
That was deep shit right there.
The Rose Garden. It's hilarious. It
was probably true. Well, what, what,
what is it about when someone just has a
colossal catastrophic fuck up like this
that makes you so uncomfortable?
I think it's because you are terrified
that you would ever see that kind of
behavior in yourself.
And you can only imagine that it could
be possible in some fucking unsprung fit
of madness that you got completely
out of control, you know,
and you were drunk or on
drugs or something and you
said Shit equally as crazy.
God Damn check,
cozy,
cozy love to have recordings
of like arguments I got in with
crazy girlfriends when I was young
and stupid. But you know what?
The one thing about this,
the one thing I thought about it at
least three or four times while I'm
listening to this is damn,
that bitch could be really psycho.
He's probably fucked up cause she
probably did some crazy shit. Maybe.
Maybe I'm just thinking maybe he,
she did some crazy shit.
Then she records it and he's not repeating
what he did because he assumes that
she already knows. I mean, of
course, you know it's, I mean he's,
you know what I'm saying?
It's crazy.
And if he's not crazy then he's
incredibly weak. That was like the week,
his version of the pimp
hand I've ever heard ever.
They don't you fucking hang up on
me. What are you talking about, son?
Why you get all his brother? He like gave
away every fucking move. First of all,
she's calm and collected.
He's screaming and yelling and
calling her a cunt. He loses.
He loses bite off the bat cause she's
like, I don't know why you're so excited.
You need medication blocked, blocked. He
fucking loses. He's trying to tear later.
It's he's doing gang or doing nothing.
He's telling her he's going to bring the
cops to her house to kick her out with
her baby and she's like, you can
do that if you want. She's like,
did she owned him? It was just like
straight domination. How dare you?
I'm just trying to, I'm just trying to
help out a brother. He's my brother.
He's weak, deprived idiot.
That's a weak, weak man.
We thought we were talking about
Braveheart. You know what I mean?
I've touched me and I'm thinking,
damn this motherfucker out.
You know what I mean? Guys can get
crazy. Great guys can get possessive.
I don't know. You know, he's
a brilliant director to that.
Apocalypto was fascinating. I loved it.
I never saw it. I hated the other one.
The Passion of the Christ to me was
like a two hour movie about a dude with
magic who got the fuck beat out of him.
I mean he could do magic tricks and
they just beat his fucking ass and then
killed them and the end and he comes
back. Oh, what a fucking movie.
Like if you take away the story of Jesus,
he take away the biblical story of it.
If you don't know that as a reference,
as a standalone movie, it's
terrible. As a standalone movie.
It's a guy who just does a few magic
tricks and they beat the fuck out of him
and kill him.
That's the whole moving to,
they've got two and part
three and when it comes,
cause a motherfucker comes back,
right. You believe that other shit,
you might as well go with it. There's
more to the story. That's as part why Mel,
that could save your fucking career.
It's hard to,
it's so funny how strong the urge is
to look into the past for a time where
things were explained and clear and you
know that we were in the presence of
divine glory and the Lord was here
on earth and walking amongst men.
It's so funny how we just have this
incredible need to look to the past.
Like as if there's something
that we knew and we forgot.
There was a connection that
we had and it was lost.
I wonder what that represents.
You know,
there's people that think that that
represents psychedelics, that this,
this whole idea of the Christ,
this whole idea of that at one point in
time were connected to God and now we're
not.
You know,
and a lot of people believe that it was
a climate change issue that mushroom
stop growing and they couldn't get them
and they couldn't use them as a regular
part of, of a, of their culture.
You is the whole basis of the sacred
mushroom and the cross that, that book.
So I wonder, man, I wonder
what the fuck that is. But God,
people are so hung up on that idea.
They love the idea of there being a person
at one point in time that really had
all the answers. It's so important
to them, you know, if the exist,
it is probably just, uh, you know, a
super enlightened guy who, you know,
figure shit out.
And people were so stupid back then
that they thought he was magical,
but really he probably never even said
he was in a fee exist. I mean, it's just,
it's,
you know,
I've heard the arguments against it and
they're much stronger than the arguments
for him existence. I know, I, I
view Brian, I go back and forth,
but if you just think about it, you
know, the Christians and the Muslims,
they fucking killed each other. They
hate each other. They, you know, the,
the Jews and the Christians
hate each other that killed,
he said slaughter each other.
So if there was, if the,
if Jesus didn't exist that Jews would
be talking about that all the time.
They say, well, he did exist, but he's
not like the son of God. But yeah,
he was a bad mother fucker and that's
not enough. And the same thing with the,
they would be all over it man.
It's just not enough evidence.
And when you were talking about
stories that are, first of all,
almost all of the biblical stories came
from somewhere else. Almost all of them.
You, you can get the, the story of
uh, the creation from the, the, the,
the epic of Gilgamesh has
like so many parallels,
almost the same exact stories are
told through many different cultures.
You get down to that Jesus
character that's in the
movies is category exists and
a lot of,
but that Jesus character is exist in
timeline so far earlier than Jesus Christ
was supposed to walk the earth as a
person. That's why I'm very skeptical.
I don't know. I know that,
who the fuck my theme,
that theme has been going on for
thousands of years. If I had to choose,
I would say he did exist based
on the Muslims and the Jews.
So watch fish but use it all the same.
They were just discussing it.
No one really knows.
If we just only discuss shit that we
had proof for then. No, no, no, I'm not,
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying don't discuss it.
What I'm saying is we have
this inclination to go
one way or the other and I
don't, I don't think it's necessarily
in something like this if I,
if you had to though, but if
you don't, you don't have to.
You know what I'm saying? You're just
a human being. Like the, we have this,
this massive inclination to go
one way or the other, you know,
do you go Jesus or atheist?
You go Mac or PC. You know,
it's an urge that we have to like to
accept whether or not someone existed.
He existed. He was just a
bad dad was a god particle.
I says, Dad was a god
particle. If you don't know,
there's a discussion and debate whether
or not the Higgs Boson particle,
the media crew named God particle,
the scientist on a called
the God particle. But what
it basically is is a, uh,
Parker that existed at the
very beginning of the universe,
the birth of the universe of
milliseconds after the big bang.
They believe that this particle existed
and they now believe there's five
different individual versions of the
Higgs Boson particle and a particle
collider in Illinois of all places is the,
the place
that they're saying that they
were about to shut down.
Supposedly it's last breath is supposedly
there's rumors that it found this and
we're going to find out in this
speech and Paris next week,
is it next week or something like that.
Or there's, there's two different,
there's two different camps on this.
Some scientists are saying that there's
no way and there's no evidence and this
is just bullshit and rumors.
And then there's other scientists
that are involved in it.
They're saying it's very clear they
have all the markings that they've
discovered this actual particle.
Yeah.
They're going to present their findings
July 22nd at the Paris international
kind of joke around
about the shit on stage.
You know about like what the fuck are we
doing? You know, because I think it's,
it is a strange thing that technology
used to be used to enhance our lives,
you know, like to create cops
and you know, electricity,
all these different things
that make our life easier.
But when you get to a certain
level of, of, of discovery,
like the Higgs Boson
particle, like, you know,
like what they're working on right now,
like these particle colliders and all
this craziness. It's like, wow, like what,
what is, what's going to come out
of here that's going to help us?
Is this going to help us at all
or is this just, we're just,
let's see if we can do this. I mean,
and there's nothing wrong with,
let's see if we can do this. If you've
got all your other shit covered, you know,
but right now, I mean, look at all the
fucking problems in the world. If the,
the number one thing that
scientists are working on is this,
is that the right thing mean it's
a totally debatable issue. I mean,
if you were the guy who got to dictate,
you know how we should fix the world,
you know, and you, you got to bring all
the scientists together and say, hey,
you know,
what should we concentrate on?
Would you say let's make little
black holes and let's, you know,
let's use the Higgs Boston,
you know, let's try to find
the Higgs Boson particle.
What would would you try to do? I
would let them do it. Jump really high.
You got to let them do it for sure.
Honestly,
spent equal time trying
to perfect big dick pills.
Put some time into that too.
Do you think if you jumped every day,
and I had some way to calculate how high
you jumped every day and he tried it
for 10 years, that the,
how big high do you think,
do you think there's like a wall
of how much you can of course,
or do you think you could, can
continue is how high are you? God Damn,
what a ridiculous question.
That's, that's like what?
I would love to be able to do that
experiment. Why don't you just do it?
I thought about it, but my people, my ex
girlfriend thought I was fucking crazy,
so I stopped. I only lasts like a
week. Fuck that bitch, man. Try it.
You could become the best jumper ever.
Be on the Olympic jumping team.
You have to tell about, my idea is that
you would have to get better every week.
You probably wouldn't ever stop.
Your muscles would grow.
You would go jump higher and higher
and well, let's put it to the test son.
I don't want to do, I don't have
that time. I don't want it to it.
Imagine if you could tell him,
listen back to what we were talking about
with the Higgs Boson particle. I don't,
I'm not criticizing, don't get me
wrong. I'm not criticizing scientists.
I'm not saying they should be
concentrating on other things.
I just think it's weird. This
obsession that we have with technology,
with like digging deeper and deeper
intellect, the heart of matter,
and they're supposed to, man, I
know. I think we're supposed to to,
I mean that's what my
whole thing on stage is.
It's a joke is about that we
create the Big Bang, you know,
that human beings are what actually
creates the big bang and crack the
universal open and starts
all over again from scratch.
Then 14 billion years later,
another human being developed
at that gets developed,
makes the big bang and
do it all over again.
Did you hear that the methane
gas bubble was debunked? That uh,
that whole thing that was
going around? Yeah, I did,
but I don't know if there's
enough data on that.
I don't know who's right and who's wrong.
I know that people that are
talking about that area,
we're talking about that they're not
letting any photograph photographers and
they're not letting reporters. Then they
have a huge problem with the, uh, um,
pollution in the air. The, uh, the oil is
not just oil on the surface of the water.
It's, there's a vapor in the air and the
parts per million of acceptable toxins.
It's through the fucking roof. So they
might have to evacuate certain areas.
It's gets a fucking
ugly, ugly, ugly scene.
You're talking about an oil spill
that's bigger than states, you know,
I mean that's,
I don't even think we can wrap our head
around how big of a disaster this is.
The ocean is gigantic,
but there's a huge part of it
that is just fucked up right now.
And we've never seen anything
on this scale in human
history that we're aware of.
Especially not in like, you
know, with Florida is that's it,
Florida. So all those, those houses
as beach front houses that problem,
what areas it's hit and what areas
it hasn't. In Houston, Texas,
they're getting those tar
bubbles are when everything is.
And parts of Florida started to get him
about two weeks or saying millions of
fish are dead.
They just put a cap on it.
They finally put some
sort of a cap to stop it.
But there's reports that there's oil
coming from more than one spot off the
ocean floor, which means that the
pipe when it blew up, um, that it's,
it's possible that there's all sorts
of ruptures further down the line,
which means it's just
good on Ustream right now.
There's nine cameras on yet. Well, but
what they're talking about is holes.
Miles.
We just take like a little submarine thing
that would go and take go or you know,
or the area you would see whales coming
out of the water. When didn't you?
Well there's guys that have photograph
things that they say are plumes that are
inside the water. I don't know.
You know there's that was,
there was a guy on CNN that was talking
about the possibilities and he was just
a,
he was a scientist that was explaining
what they're trying to do right now with
the cap and what does worst case scenario,
and he said that worst case scenario was
there was holes in other parts of the
pipe further down the line.
He said,
but that right now appears to be
highly unlikely. So he doesn't know.
So they said that his worst case scenario,
and if people online are saying that
it, that is the case, who knows?
We don't know. It's almost like a
media blackout. Like you're only,
you're only allowed to get a
certain amount of information.
There's people from a citizen's radio
they put on that Jamie Kilstein dude.
And Allison Kilkenny,
they put on a bunch of stuff on Twitter
where all these people that live on the
Gulf are a accusing BP of dumping sand
onto oil that's washed up on the beach
and they proved it.
They have videos of it on youtube where
they're showing the sand and they're
showing the black shit
that's underneath the sand.
You know like the show him like layers.
They're like,
they came with trucks and they dumped
sand on top of this oil instead of
cleaning the oil up there, like making it
a little bit, the oil doesn't exist. Wow.
That's fucking crazy shit.
But you know,
they do that all the time.
Putting sand and rearranging sands on
beaches. That's just a part of each too,
you know? Oh, maybe it was
just regular maintenance. Not
if they cover all the oil.
That doesn't make any sense. They have,
I mean they bring in Santa beaches,
they fucking rate beaches every morning
at some point because having a place
that's a lot of sand. I'm just thinking.
I'm saying the other side, you know,
there's no proof that they fucking really
take this sand to a whole coastline.
When have they ever done that?
What have they ever gone?
Miles and miles down to beach daily.
They do it daily.
It's called maintaining beaches,
beaches, some beaches, a lot.
Mostly public beaches.
They do that all the time where
they just drive up with trucks,
redo beaches all the time.
What did they do?
Did they actually bring sand everyday
replaced sand from the back of the s know
at the top front, you know, to keep it
the beach going, we need to Google this.
Are they rotating the sand?
I think we need to Google this.
Why don't you Google Google,
Google,
uh,
BP covering oil with sand and see if we
could find that article and see what it
says exactly. Because we're
starting to delve into the world of,
we don't know what the fuck
we're talking about. But anyway,
the bottom line is this is a giant
fucking disaster. It's a scary one, man.
I'm not saying that scientists should
stop working on the Higgs Boson particle
and stop working on the large Hadron
collider. I mean, I think the whole,
I think you should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want to do.
I'm not contributing to society.
These guys are,
it could fuck up clean the oil spill.
Yeah. No, I mean there's,
there's out there, you know,
they're saying that they did it. I
just did a porky pig there. There's,
there's some sort of like microbes
that they built. Yeah, there said this.
The allegations.
Yeah.
There's some sort of microbe that they've
developed that he consumes oil and you
can pour it on top of the oil
and it actually eats the oil.
I wonder if they could do it on that
kind of a scale now maybe it would take
over. It would become some giant fucking
blob and eat in New York. You know,
once it gets hungry for oil runs out of
oil that it starts eating tires and shit.
Need to dump some vinegar in the
ocean and let it push it to our tires.
Tires are made out of oil.
Right. Isn't it? Yeah.
Tires are made out of petroleum
fuel tires, right? You need it.
You need oil for most things. You can
imagine if there's a fucking disease,
like a microbe that started eating
people's tires and somehow or another got
over here from the, the, the
Gulf efforts when they pour,
if they poured the stuff into the ocean
and some of it got out and they started
like throwing on the streets in New
York and I started eating people's cars,
eat your tires and shit, eat
your sneakers, you can't walk in.
It becomes a goddamn epidemic.
We have to change over to hemp,
hemp,
everything that could really happen.
It could really,
what's the problem with drinking bottled
water? Well, there's a lot of people that
it's wasteful and a lot of
people that think that, uh,
you know, you use up so much
oil in the construction of a bottle of
water and then the recycling is only so
efficient and you're constantly
contributing to this, uh, you know,
ecological ecological disaster we have
right now with recyclables and plastics
and you know, all the shit that's in the
ocean right now. Carbon cycle business,
the fucking scam now, is that
what they're saying? Well,
Penn and teller thing about
bullshit and credible,
I think penitentiary did a whole
episode of bullshit on it. Yeah.
I don't remember the results though.
There's some times where you just
got to say, and obviously recycling,
it's not a scam. You know, Penn
and teller ever done an episode
at Penn and teller ever done an episode
of bullshit where they decided something
that isn't bullshit when they were done.
No. They went and did that episode,
do you think? Oh, I don't
know. They should do.
And then you got up, you got
it. You got to mix it up.
They turn into an episode of martial
arts man saying that martial arts lessons
for the money you'd save,
you'd be better off just giving it
to the mugger by not taking them.
If you have the money you save by
not taking martial arts lessons,
you'd be better off just,
I mean they have to find that conclusion,
they have to find them.
But that's just the dumbest doesn't
have an open mind. That's not only that,
that's someone who has never worked out.
You don't understand the benefits,
the clarity, these tall fucked up. Right.
He's a great guy. I love that dude.
Somebody asked me that. I'm on factor. I
had him on fear factor or I had him on,
he was on with uh, with teller
and I became buddies with them,
became email buddies,
came to the comedy store a few times and
I hung out with him and did his radio
show a couple of times too when
those moon hoax debates. But he's a,
he's a great guy.
Somebody asked me the other day who
would win between you two and a fight.
And I immediately see, I said
Eddie, cause I know he could,
he's tapped you 12 years old.
Who would win in a fight?
[inaudible] the bullshit MMA may
question. And because you know,
that's another thing, what
they're saying is, you know,
like if you do certain MMAs
it's not gonna protect.
You did a straight Jujitsu match who
you'd kicked my ass, taps me all the time.
I'd ever even come close to tapping
into a real fight Jelica class.
Then I was like, wait, no, no wait, Joe
could like punch him in my standards.
My kick boxing is probably
better than my Jujitsu. You know,
I don't really do it anymore and
just don't forget about that.
You always forget about that. You just
spoke. But if we were the same size too,
I'm still,
I'm like 30 pounds heavier than I was
getting swole. Yeah. So anyway,
so that's, that is a thing though.
Like if you're in a bar fight and you're,
you know,
Jujitsu is two people per set of
bar fights is who hit who first.
That's the 90% you know,
just in 90% of avoiding bar
fights is don't go to shitty bars.
Don't hang out with Douche bags. Get
away when you see things are going bad,
right? When people started acting Douchey,
you see a comment, it's in the air,
you smell it. Defensive drivers to people.
Be careful. You see creep, stay away.
There's nothing worse than
drunk. Motherfucking due
to been rejected all night.
The club,
some guys get wrong,
so aggro man,
chicks just rejected them all night and
then they see you with your girl and
there's like three of them
and they just can't fucking,
they can't help themselves
and they can't help being disrespectful
to Saul. So unnecessary man.
It's so fucking hard for people to
get their shit together so hard.
There's so many dickheads out there.
They're doing.
The bottom line is the war
were saying about martial arts.
It's not even about learning
how to fight it. That's your,
you're rarely going to use that. If it
was just about learning how to fight,
like man, how often does
it even come up? You know,
you're just preparing for
something that probably,
if you're a smart person will
never happen you in your life,
but you get a shit load of benefits
from it. It's not, it's like, you know,
when you play chess, you don't just
play chess to learn how to, you know,
finish this one game.
And when you play chess to learn the
strategy and to become involved in like
long term planning out of,
you know,
any sort of a situation you can
apply chest to your life, you know,
and the same thing as Jujitsu,
same thing as any kind of martial art.
You get better at anything that's really
difficult and it makes you better at
everything else you do as
well. Like jumping, yeah.
Could you do to helps your music
and your music helps you Jujitsu.
Ah, well let's talk about your seminars
before you answer that question.
Where are they? Okay. I got a couple of
seminars coming up. I got Omaha, Nebraska,
10 planet Omaha in not this Saturday,
but next Saturday.
And then I'm going to be at,
um, the very next Saturday,
July 31st I'll be at,
uh,
the future home of 10th Planet
Charlotte for all the information,
just go to 10th planet j J.
Dot Com
and that's where they can order all your,
your DVDs and
yeah, you've got a 10 pound at
J J. Dot Com. Call on the forum.
Then you'd be reform and all
of the information. Just know,
look for the Charlotte or the Omahas
seminar and there'll be a flyer up and
you're all good.
Now, don't you think that Jujitsu helps
you music and music helps with Jujitsu?
Don't you think that anytime you,
you like,
you get great at anything in your life
that enhances all the other things in
your life?
Yes, definitely. Um,
but with Jujitsu you see constantly with
Jujitsu is you see yourself as a total
retard with a certain move. And then
you see yourself practice and get good,
and then you master it.
And you constantly see that with all these
different moves, Jujitsu, so gigantic,
there's a million different paths.
You need three lifetimes to
master the whole game of Jujitsu.
I mean I've been doing too just to 16
years. I got a lot of holes in my game,
but I'm good at the stuff that I focused
on and the stuff I focused on and put
the numbers in. The reps,
you see that constant.
So you see that our bodies are magical.
Our Bot,
we have two people inside
of us, the conscious person
and the unconscious person,
and you are,
you want to train the conscious person
so much that that unconscious person,
the other dude, you've done it so
much that he's going to do it all.
Then you become the executive producer.
You know like when someone
shredding on piano,
they're not calling out the
commands like this key, that key,
that key they did out in the beginning,
but after awhile it's like
you're executive producing,
you have a song in your head,
you look down,
you're looking at a certain area and Bam,
that person inside of
you does it like magic.
So once you see it in Jujitsu over
and you'll realize that our bodies are
magical. Then a work, not just
for Jujitsu but for anything.
If you decided to play tennis, guess
what? The longer you play tennis,
the longer you put the hours in it,
the better you get at most.
People don't see that.
Most people don't have any confidence
in themselves whatsoever with anything
they think they can't do that.
They think that'll never happen.
You can actually do anything. You
really can. You'll get good at anything.
If you focus on it, you're, you
put the numbers, you put the reps.
That's what it's all about.
The only thing that's different between
me and a white belt in Jujitsu is the
number of,
of of reps that I've put in with
my certain style and you know,
and in Jujitsu you realize that and it
brings your whole other life up because
in other aspects of your life, your day
job or your longterm goal, your dream,
you'll realize, damn, all I gotta do is
put the numbers in whatever direction
it is.
It definitely,
Jujitsu definitely shows
you in any martial art and
any difficult endeavor shows
you what your potential is and how you
can expand your potential as a human
being. But what it doesn't
give you is creativity.
Creativity is a totally different
thing that's attached to,
to ambition and to, you
know, focus and intensity.
There's something about creativity
that comes from a very pure place, but,
and you could be a hard
worker all you want, but you,
you might not necessarily necessarily
been able to be able to tap into the well
of creativity. You know what I'm talking
about? Sure. You gotta be born with,
you're pretty creative with your moves
in Jiu Jitsu. So that isn't there. Like,
wouldn't there be that creativity is
an art. Jujitsu is an art. I mean,
martial arts are arts, you know, more
ties and art. There's an art to, like,
whenever I say, like I'm doing
commentary and I'll say, look,
look at this beautiful combination. It is
beautiful to me. I'm not just saying it,
that's, that's the, that's
an art form. That's, it just
led to me, that's a painting.
That's a, you know, an incredible dance.
That's a, you know, that's a, a work, uh,
a masterpiece.
Like my favorite is when Anderson Silva
finished off rich Franklin in the second
fight.
There's a fucking combination where
like nine out of 10 shots land and he's
landing punches and knees to the body
and he's mixing them up and it's fucking
poetry. It's ballet, you know,
that's an artist doing that. Man.
Jiu Jitsu is even more creative than
that because there's so many more moves
with kickboxing, you know, in Indian
wrestling and whatever, there's, you know,
there's take downs and there's controls
and there's a lot of different reversals
and stuff like that. But with Jujitsu
that just the path to the submissions,
the tree has so many branches and there's
so many different ways to approach
each aspect of the game. From
the bottom, from the top,
it does so many different sweeps and
reversals and so many different half guard
techniques and full guard techniques. It's
impossible to come to an end, you know,
it's, it's out of control and,
and my Jujitsu and my music, it's,
there are so parallel in so many ways.
It's like in Jujitsu,
I am not an athlete. I'm not
explosive. I am not powerful.
I can't run fast. I can't jump
high. I am not an athlete.
Never was. Even when I wrestled in
high school for a couple of years,
I got away on tricks.
That's,
I had to think my way past the athletes
and just to be able to hang with like
the real serious athlete. I'm not an
athlete. Same thing with my music.
I am not a virtuoso at any instrument.
I don't shred on anything.
I just put it all together,
you know? And, and it's, it's,
it's a strange parallel that Ah,
you know, but it's creativity. Yeah.
Because your did,
you did choose a very creative Jujitsu
to the most creative in my opinion.
And you know,
we're friends and I'm not supposed
to say that cause it sounds like,
oh that's bullshit. But it is, if I was
just a, a Jujitsu analyst, I would say,
well here's a guy who's, I mean there's a
lot of creative guys, be no sham breeze,
creative, you know, so many
different cards were created.
But as far as like putting it together
in a system of all these weird different
positions, in 90% of them
you have invented and the
ones you haven't, you know,
your credit, all the different individuals
that contributed to whatever move.
That's a, that's an unusual thing, man.
That's an incredibly prolific career
of just creating Jujitsu and putting it
down. I mean, very few human
beings have ever done that. Yeah.
Thank you.
Look at your system,
Mueller gear system. I mean, and,
and all the different techniques
that you've added to, you know,
to the whole Nogi game.
It's a lot of God damn technique.
You know what my,
I think my strongest point is that
I don't like being raised with just,
you know,
the terrible household.
I mean with my Stepdad and my real dad
and no one cares and then constantly
watching TV with sitcoms where
everything is just perfect.
I just never believed anything.
I thought everyone was bullshitting me.
So the same thing when I
came into martial arts.
I'm not loyal to any martial art.
I don't care. And growing up,
listening to Bruce Lee and listening to
what he had to say about opening your
mind and don't follow one style.
I was really influenced by Bruce Lee
and he was right to me because my family
was just not, it was not growing pains.
My family was not the Brady bunch.
It was terrible. So I just questioned
everything. So as soon as karate,
it's karate seemed good. I started with
karate. Susan's that didn't pan out.
I saw Jujitsu, I was gone. I
didn't give a shit about karate.
I went to do Jitsu and as soon as
I saw the Jujitsu started becoming,
um,
what they were claiming,
the traditional martial arts were
becoming just the Brazilian jujitsu became
close minded. And I was
like, I'm not going to key in
some circles. Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So some guys
are love really open mind. Generally.
Generally 99% of the Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
community thinks 10th planet Jiu Jitsu,
this mythical generally. But
there are some people, you know,
not everybody does that frustrate
the shit out of you or what, what does
that feel like when you got, you know,
all these guys, Vinny Magallanes,
all these like high level guys,
George Sada Rapa lists, you know, they,
they go fucking crazy for it and they,
they totally fully believe in that system.
But then you've got other guys
that are like saying, Oh, you know,
you didn't invent the, we've been doing
the, what do you think about that?
I love it man.
I love the stronger the resistance,
the longer it takes for 10
planet to become, uh, get uh, um,
uh, become, uh, any, you know,
not mythical as long, the
longer it takes, the better.
It's just going to be sweeter at
the end. I love it. I love the,
if there was no resistance to my
philosophies and let's say in 2003 if I,
when I decided not to teach with the g,
I decided to open up the school Nogi
and let's say Helio Gracie back then and
Carlene hos. If they said, you know
what? This American is making a point.
The reason why Jujitsu isn't doing
that good in MMA anymore is the geek.
All right? Everybody is ordered
to start teaching without the g.
If they just all jumped on with me
because I was doing this for Jujitsu.
I wasn't doing it to battle
against the Brazilian Jujitsu.
I was doing it for Jujitsu.
I'm like MMA.
It was doing it because that's
what you believe. I was a big,
Jujitsu was in my heart. Jujitsu is, I
was doing it for Jujitsu. I was like,
let's bring Jujitsu back in MMA.
We've got to get rid of the geese.
If everyone would agreed with
me back then that first of all,
the state of no Jujitsu
would be out of this world.
It would be crazy if everybody joined
in and just not me and my association.
If we all just agreed and you know,
there would be a, you know, 500 guys,
it's just like
Burleson as podcasts. I have no
fucking idea what we're talking about.
So let me just explain, uh, there's a, uh,
a whole different to two
different types of Jujitsu,
good Jujitsu with a Kimono or a g,
you know,
it's like that karate uniform on and a
lot of guys do that and those Jujitsu
that you use Gnocchi and there's a
big thing called the Abu Dhabi world
championships and that's where all the
best Gnocchi guys in the world fight.
And the Nogi style is what you're going
to see in MMA because when you see guys
use a gay all the time,
they're grabbing the GE and they get used
to controlling their opponent with the
biggie. Then when they have
to fight in the octagon,
they have no Geeta hold onto in.
A lot of them look lost.
And that's responsible for a lot of
the early UFC fights having really good
Jujitsu guys, but they couldn't do
shit when they fell. They're back.
They couldn't do anything in
certain positions to handles. Yeah.
There used to handle not Eddie devise
the whole system entirely based on Nogi.
He abandoned diggy and when he started
teaching he just went total like MMA
style.
Does he give you all the keys that
he's abandoned because you have a whole
closet full of ice right there.
Them bitches.
Think if you're wearing to 500
keys and even working anymore,
what was the question? When we're talking
about, we're just talking about Jujitsu,
being frustrated that you don't get the
credit that you deserve. I like it, man.
I love him. I love what's going on right
now. Is that with me in burst? Why?
Why even worry about that? Right? Just
concentrate, keep doing the good stuff.
I love every day, man. I'm, I
realized and it would if I don't,
if I didn't really think about it
like maybe five, six years ago,
it did bother me. It did
bother me that, you know,
when I decided to open up a
school without a geek for Jujitsu,
the people that I was doing it for,
they turn their back on me and they
made me out to be like this trader.
It's interesting. I'm a trader and I'm
like, no, I'm doing this for us man.
It's interesting.
We were talking about how
growing up in a shitty household that
when you have this fucked up family life
and then you see bullshit on television,
how it makes you question everything.
You're forced to question everything.
And I had the exact same experience.
My life was not nearly as Shitty as yours,
but there was a lot of problems. One,
my dad was super violent and used to beat
my mom and I saw it when I was a young
kid. I saw it when I was like five.
And um, I'll never forget that shit.
I'll never forget thinking that my dad
was like my hero. I thought, you know,
my dad was like this cool guy and I saw
my dad smacked my mother in the face
over nothing and dropped her
right in the kitchen floor.
And I went running into the room to hide.
And I'll never forget thinking at that
moment in time, I can't trust anybody.
They might all be fucking
crazy. Everybody's wrong.
I knew there was no reason.
My fault,
my,
this is what my mom went to
go get something for dinner
and she came back home
with hamburger and that's why he hit her.
He was like hamburger and he
fucking smacked in the face.
And so from that moment
on, like literally, I've,
I've questioned everything.
That's what made me become a standup
comedian. You know, people who say, Oh,
were you a class clown? I mean, I said
funny shit every now and then in class.
But what I would really was, was
the clash questioner, you know,
I was the class guy. The guy would go,
well, why are you even saying that?
That doesn't make any sense.
What about this? You know, I was,
the guy would get in trouble for asking
questions. Oh, that was me too, man.
It all depended on the teacher. If the
teacher was weak and she had a big heart,
I crushed. I was the loudest
always causing disruptions.
But if Mr Enders,
he didn't give a fuck.
And so I was quiet as hell. I remember
this girl told me what you think,
you're so quiet in here, but in Miss
Aspens class you're out of control.
Did I gave her a nerve?
I gave to teachers and nervous breakdown
this Franklin and [inaudible] and in
the 10th grade Miss Aspen,
I feel really well.
I was proud of it back then and um,
I,
I wouldn't be proud of it now if I like,
you know,
kind of in a time machine and I went back,
I would feel really bad
that happened so long ago,
but I think she might
be alright. I got, uh,
I got kicked out of school for drawing
cartoons of teachers. I would grow,
draw cartoons, a teacher's fucking and
like they're really looked like them,
you know. And uh, I drew this one
Spanish teacher. She, uh, I uh,
had her without her makeup. I drew with
she where she'd wear a ton of makeup.
So I do with her makeup and then I
drew one without her makeup and uh,
I got expelled or suspended,
rather kicked out of school.
I remember like real clearly though,
like the first laugh I ever got was
like the first time I was like, wow,
that was kind of cool. Was in a math
class where a teacher was upset at me.
It's just teacher.
She had this really strong urban accent,
quote unquote and uh, she was his math
teacher and she was like, really? Um,
just like, just aggressively
conti. I just didn't like her.
I didn't like her class. And uh, I
was talking apparently and she goes,
miss or Rogan,
since you know everything,
would you like to come up here and do
both of these problems with his class?
So I go, would you like me
to do both of them problems?
And the whole place fell the fuck out.
Like dudes just start laughing and
slap and tables and she goes, go ahead,
laugh at Mr Rogan. Mr Rogan is
going nowhere in life. And uh,
she suspended me.
She sent me to the Dean and they suspended
me for fucking just me. Come on, man.
You're teaching math. You don't even know
how to talk English. This is nonsense.
As a dumb conversation,
I would shoot spit wads and Ms. Franklin.
Sarah,
she had a big bouffant hairdo
and we would shoot speak bonds.
We would do some terrible stuff.
I was terrible when I was bored.
When I was bored, I just did not want
to pay attention. I didn't give a fuck.
I wouldn't fuck around and guys classes
though. I wasn't on the fuck. I'm like,
I'm not Mr. Reed.
My Sixth Grade Algebra teacher,
Mr fucking read it was me,
Bobby joys.
And is this the Cambodian chick named
pool? Muah. Right? Poor Melissa. It was,
we laughed. He would get
really mad. So it was hard.
Me and Bobby tried to go above
a choice and go here. Oh,
Edgar Bravo. Okay. A pool.
He was saying that black boys,
dude, it was hard to contain.
I'll never forget pool at Moma.
Just some something about
schools, man, where you really,
it's not just learning shit,
you're,
you're going in there and
this intense environment,
it's like preparing you for work.
You know,
you're getting prepared for like intense
social environments doing shit you
don't want to do around a bunch of people.
You don't want to be around forced
into a room together, you know?
And that's a credible that
we put so little effort into
making sure teachers are
good.
I mean it's a really amazing,
they should get paid about the same as
doctors of some sorts and these family
agrees to that everybody.
But if nothing's happening,
no one's doing anything about everybody
agrees on it, you know, it'd be cool.
Why does it make pot legal and have
like put 10% of pot go to pay teachers?
How about that? Or they should just charge
money for school. That's what I think.
No,
nobody would go to school,
man. People can't. People are barely
getting by. Especially people with kids.
They're barely getting by.
You can't make them pay for school.
But it's just incredible that we have
all this money for fucking relief to
Israel and all this money for, you
know, the Afghan war and the Iraqi war.
We got all this money, but we don't
have enough money for fucking teachers.
That's incredible that we
care so much about our future,
that we want to deal with the problems
that we have right now and spend every
fucking doll.
We have thrown money at it,
but we don't want to look
at the foundation of what
causes fucking problems in
our own country. What causes
so much crime, which causes
so much civil disarray.
Skulls, show retards. Somebody
dummies school should have
some kind of profit though.
You know,
they should do some kind
of like advertising. You're
not like have banner ads.
There's, you know, they need
to update the school system.
Probably like overhaul and change.
Make it fun.
Isn't it weird that it's actually weird
because you're paying taxes for it, man.
What if, what if there was like reality
shows based on third graders? You know, we
need, it needs to be fun for
kids. That's where kids learn.
Kids learn when it's fun.
Everything is not supposed to be boring.
Everything is not supposed to suck.
That's not natural.
And the reason why kids hate it is
because it feels like shit. It's not fun.
There's gotta be a way to
make becoming enlightened,
becoming educated and you know,
becoming, you know, having your,
your life enriched with new information
that should be fun for kids. Positive,
you know,
the fact that we set them up with fucking
shitty teachers and shitty schools and
under motivated people that can't
control people like Eddie in their class.
Old Ladies, I'll kill an old lady dude's
I had this one dude,
Mr. White and Mr. White was a Vietnam vet
and always wanted to tell us about it.
I always want to tell us about
Vietnam and he, you would always snap.
Like if you asked for a pencil
one time we asked for a pencil,
some doodads for pencil.
Mr. White pulls out his desk drawer
to browse it across the floor,
filled with pencils and shit.
Hurls this shit. He goes,
go get a pencil, go pick up
a pencil. And the kid got up,
grabbed pencil,
went back at,
sit down and nobody said a fucking word
for the rest of the class were like this
to just through a drawer
filled with pencils. Like,
are you allowed to do that today? That
brought guy would probably be in jail,
but I used to have a teacher like I
would always sleep in class and he would
come and full on soccer,
kicked the bottom of the
table so you bet Bam,
you know fucking it would wake you up
and scare the fuck out of you at the same
time. It was the worst and
it fucking hurt. It was a,
it was like that much desk in between
him kicking me in the fucking head.
Help Mood
Mr. Allen,
Jason Alan's dad wrestler. But
when a, when a spit Wad lady,
she had a nervous breakdown and we
brought in a substitute teacher,
big buff dude. He was going to
come in and he heard about me.
I wasn't going to fuck with them
but I still make the class laugh.
He would actually make me stand in a
corner if I do, I wouldn't do anything.
I was just standing there and people
were laughing cause like my face. Yeah,
I would just wait him and he made you
stand in a corner but you didn't do
anything to be made to stand in the
corner. Little things with my face,
like I wasn't, how'd you get stuck
in the corner? I don't remember.
But I do remember being in the corner and
just like really being end to the wall.
Like I was staring at the wall and people
were still laughing and that guy said
fuck this class.
Cause he couldn't really do anything
to me because I wasn't saying anything.
I would just stand in and everybody was
watching me. So no matter what I did,
he just went insane too.
Wow. What a nightmare. Yeah,
it was crazy, man. You got a lot
of pleasure out of that. Right?
We would turn off the light. She would
have, the crazy thing is we weren't,
I mean never became a comedian.
I will.
I did do it a little bit
and I tried it nine times.
How come you didn't keep going?
Because I realized that just like Jujitsu,
just like surfing,
just like mountain biking,
if you want to get really good at it,
you got to spend a lot of time crafting
it and putting together, you know, uh,
10 minutes, sad of 15 minutes and
then I realize, wow, you can't,
this isn't something that you can
just get up on stage and you're a bad
motherfucker.
You have to carefully crafted practice it,
go up to all these open mics. You got
to, you know, it's a, it's an art.
And I realized, man, I don't
have time for another arc.
Like I would like to learn how to surf.
I don't have time for,
I would like to learn how to motocross,
like with the motorcycles and jumping
Dirk things and all that shit.
I would love that, but I
don't have, there's, there's
not enough time in the day.
So I decided,
you know what the best move is to
just fucking focused on Jiu Jitsu
and music and that's it, man.
I gotta I gotta I can't be spreading
myself. Then Todd White told me that.
He goes, dude, you're
spreading yourself. Then dude,
that's not good focus and I'm like,
you know what I got and plus it's sucked.
Big gigantic donkey balls,
buffalo balls to bomb on stage and
like at least half the time I bombed.
I just like too nervous man.
I was just super nervous.
I went up there and it was just death.
I'll never forget the worst time I bombed.
I came off and Joe,
because I was Joe's project and my Joe
had shit riding on me because he was
happy meat cut in line at Sunday night
open mic night when there's like 50
people waiting in line all day. Joe would
just say put them on right before me.
Like I would cut in and the comedians
that go with this fucking bullshit,
but Joe was running the comedy store so
they would just put me in no experience
ever. I go on stage and a couple of
times I did our light and Joe, can I go?
Oh I do. That was pretty good too.
That was pretty good. We got to we,
I like what you said about that. Like we
said about that. Now let's do this now.
Cut that out, edit this out. The worst
bombing I came out, Joe said, all right,
can I follow me?
So he takes her to the fucking back
and like I could see him thinking like,
how are we going to do this?
Cause it was like he had a safe space
to like it was for him, you know?
And it was really bad. It was like
the stripper, like it was like,
I didn't even tell jokes, I just
went on stage. I was just obsessed.
Like I had [inaudible] had some good,
some bits. You had some bids. The one,
the two that I,
that that did the best was when I
talked about when I had sex with a one,
one grown, a rag in the total darkness.
And then when I turned on the light,
it was just, just blood
everywhere. That was all right.
People were kind of
into that a little bit.
And then the other one was about my dad,
the very first time I went up.
That's the, gave me the
confidence. First Time I went up,
I talked about my dad and went
to Dicky was or something.
And I got a couple of laughs
and I was like, Damn. Oh my God,
I think I could do this. Oh Shit,
I think I could do this. Fuck that.
Comedy Store Open Mike Night,
there's an air of sad and pathetic.
There's like a,
a vibe in the air that's very difficult
to cut through and especially during
those open Mike night
sets, those are, it's like,
like you don't even really know what
comedy is when you're doing those cause
you're,
you're doing them for these weird crowds
that have only seen people eat shit for
fucking the last hour and a
half. Anybody any good, you know,
I mean that's how it is in the beginning.
Open Mike Nights, they're terrible.
I was terrible in the beginning.
Everyone is terrible in the beginning
and you're, you're going, you know,
there's five, six, seven terrible
people in a row there. W It's weird.
It was kind of,
shows are so weird.
I had to make a choice,
man.
That was the last time I was on stage
as the comedy store Sunday night.
And I don't know, after I got off I was
like, you know what, I'm just, I don't,
like you said, I need to put way
more energy and this and I'm not,
I'm not spending three hours
that night at the comedy store.
I
think it's one of those things that
it has to be a big focus of your life.
You can't, I mean, even when
I've put it on the side,
even while I've been doing it for so long,
you know,
like when I was doing news radio for
a long time, I was not anything new.
I was not putting much effort into comedy
at all. It wasn't excited about it.
I was like, all of a sudden I was on this
TV show and I was like, you know, going,
wow, I guess I'm doing
TV shows now. You know?
And I'm just still going to kind of
do stand up just to keep it, you know,
that's my base. That's where I started,
but I wasn't passionate about it.
So for like a good solid two years,
I just didn't write much. I didn't,
I went on stage and then I
bombed a couple times man.
And I had some people come to see me and
I had a bad set and I realize I'm like,
you know, I am not putting
a lot of effort into this.
Like this is like some weird shit where
I'm like, I'm doing comedy. Like you know,
recreationally every now and then.
But I'm known as a comedian so I'm going
up and I'm not having good sets. It's,
they're not tight.
And so I totally read dedicated,
this is like right before my first
album in 1999 and like 96 97 I had,
I had some though. Those are the years,
like 96 97 when I was barely doing comedy,
I'd go up, I'd do a set every now and
then, but I didn't give a shit about it.
It's not even that I didn't
give a shit about it.
I was just so caught up with the fact
that I was on a television show and that's
where all my effort was going to. It
was, it was one of the first jokes.
You remember the oldest one had
a gun? Oh, they're all terrible.
I remember one, I remember
a bad one about, um,
this is my impression of a good looking
girl getting pulled over by a cop.
Do you realize how fast you're
going? No. Do you like my tits
daddy?
Yeah,
he has a duty as a warning.
That was one of my earliest bits.
Oh Shit.
One of my other earlier
that's was Julia child getting
eaten out by a raccoon.
That was like open like date too.
Oh, so stupid. I love
that. That's so dumb.
I mean,
this is silly.
This is the shit that I would think
was funny when I was 21, you know,
this is the,
this is where law came from.
And you know what's funny too is the one
that another major factor was outlawed.
It was always running through my mind.
I was like,
how can I ever be as good as Joe?
You know,
we were talking about we had the same.
We would, if I put some time into,
we would end up being kind of like that.
We talk about the same things and you were
just so good. You, you know, you still,
I mean you're, you're fucking
amazing. It was just like,
how the fuck can I ever get back on?
I just got to focus on
good to done it and anybody can do it.
It's if you're funny,
if you're good at comedy
and your objective,
you have a lot of time and you have to
be objective and you have to just focus
on it and just make it something
that you concentrate on.
You know what helps me the most is I'm
listening to myself and listening to
tapes and evaluating so important. All
that stuff's so important. You can do it.
Anybody could do it. All you have to do
is just do it. It's just like Jujitsu.
All you have to do is just put the
energy into it, put the effort into it.
You'd figure it out and not having a
girlfriend or boyfriend, a boyfriend,
if you're talking about
if your girl, some girl, if
you're talking about con men here,
so talking about comics,
I don't necessarily think that's true.
I think everybody's got
different situation and sometimes it's
good to have a girlfriend because then
you feel like you're, you have comfort.
You know, I know a lot of dudes who,
you know,
the,
the world of standup comedy is like,
you know, it's fucking scary to them.
You know, you're out there on your
own, try to make it, trying to,
having someone that you live with that
supports you to a lot of people that
gives them energy and strength,
you know?
So a lot of people like they do way better
having a girlfriend or being married,
everybody's got their own thing.
But if you have a girlfriend,
she's got to be understanding
that you spend all these time,
all this time at the clubs. You have to
be constantly working almost every night.
You have to be out doing it,
especially in the beginning.
That will kill the relationship is it
tells your social and that's material,
right?
Cause your social life,
but then your social life becomes
like the comedy club world,
which is when dudes start cannibalizing.
It's what I call cannibalizing is when
a male comedian starts dating a female
comedian, they become cannibals.
Start eating their own. Yeah.
As soon as you start doing
that you're fucked. Right.
How many guys have pulled that off?
There's like three Tommy Segura and his
wife are both hilarious and cool. That's,
that's that one works. But other than
that, huh? That shit don't work son.
My friend was telling me about when he
broke up with his girlfriend that I,
she's on,
she's on a TV show,
like a popular TV show and that one
day he was feeling so down and he's,
he comes to his apartment
and his neighbors watching
24 don't say the name of
this show.
There's only two girls in that
whole show that's guessing game now.
But like how,
like they had their windows open and he
was just like walking up to his door and
suddenly you heard is I heard a
voice or whatever, like voice,
just haunting him ever.
There's billboards when he's
driving around and it was like,
well that kind of sucks living in this
city to the f two one point. Like,
I only want to date gaffers and
key grips now you now, because I,
I don't want to like date and actors and
have her make it big and then have her
fucking everywhere I go, I go, you know,
I'm already having problems like that.
Being at the airport right now, you know,
and seeing Whoa, look good. You look good.
Is Lindsay Lohan? You
know, but uh, you know,
I'm talking about how high is this
motherfucker. He's just, yeah,
you definitely don't want very tricky.
You date Angelina Jolie and
the [inaudible] and she's
on the cover of people
magazine. Fucking some new
dude. You're like, whoa. Like
that shits at the airport.
That's rough. Yeah, no, he
grips. I just think that my,
one of the reasons why I think
comics should not take comics,
why called cannibalism is cause you're
there too much like you, you know,
I don't think that's how a
relationship works out well.
I think relationships work out
well when you're different,
when you different enjoy each other's
company, but you're different.
You're two totally different things
when you're both trying to make it as a
comic man.
Fucking good luck.
Good luck with the balance of
needing this there. You know?
And I'm not saying I'm a picnic,
I'm not saying any comics a picnic.
I'm saying a comic in a comic together.
That's like two magnets, you know?
I mean maybe it'll work.
I mean I would never say it wouldn't work.
Your situation could be
totally different than mine.
Especially when you're a comic that
and you're in the La comic scene.
It's pretty tight. So when you break
up your fucking in shows with your ex,
but that's what our problem
with our friends. We have to,
we have two friends and one
friend broke up with his girl.
Or should I say the girl broke up with
him and, uh, he was very upset by this.
It was a devastating breakup.
And right afterwards, our friend,
a very good friend, starts dating
this chick and got really creepy,
but ask permission first,
got permission to Fucker,
which I think is the most hilarious
thing, fucker. Just don't date her.
Like you can't say that,
first of all,
I don't think you can
tell anybody what to do.
And then the guy chose his own medicine
and so, you know, and if for the guy,
the guy who wound up dating this girl
who was his friend's ex girlfriend,
you know, for him it's like, well,
here's this perfect person for me
and what I'm supposed to, you know,
I'm supposed to let this go just cause
some other asshole can't get over the
fact that, you know, come
on man, get over it dude,
you would hurt it didn't have a thing
together. But I'm in love with her.
I'm gonna spend the rest
of my life with her now.
I can't because you got hurt feelings.
Fuck you.
So I could see his point of view too, but
not me. I could never do it. I would not.
That's to me that there's other women
out there. I don't care how cool she is.
You've got to respect the feelings.
You want to hurt your fucking friend.
You want to hurt your friend over some
pussy. Especially if they were good.
Since I looked at every girl that used
to date one of my friends as a guy,
you only rape. That's it.
Rape Him. No relationships
could only be a one night stand.
Only in the but no, you gotta.
You gotta say that's off limits forever.
There's a lot of human
beings in this life.
You don't want to make someone
upset for no reason. I'm like that.
You could avoid that shit. The problem is
people can decide that this is the one.
He's the one, you know? Especially
if they can't have you bitches. Man.
Do you think that celebrities,
celebrity marriages,
have ended up in divorce at the same
rate as just regular marriages? Way more,
way more way. You think so? For sure.
People in this city period. That shit son,
let's find out. But I would say yeah,
for sure. It was crazy assholes.
How many Mel Gibson's out there can
keep a fucking marriage. She got out.
How did Mel Gibson's wife
stay with his ass for so long?
That's what I want to know about. I'll a
lid marriages money. Is that what it is?
And he's not Gibson man.
How do you break up?
Braveheart is worth $1 billion.
Craziest fuck
uh,
whatever. What are you finding? It
just says Duh, Duh. No, just kidding.
No it doesn't. I haven't found anything
that's kind of a hard guy. Who, well,
how could you even judge?
I mean it just sent bright percentage
of celebrities break up as opposed to
percentage of civilians.
Civilians.
Isn't it weird how um,
like pick the most, uh,
the biggest players of all end up like
rock stars and Super Actors and all that
shit?
It's like they always end up marrying
and settling down with another celebrity.
It's like the bitch has got to be a
celebrity or it's not good enough. Right?
I think it's because first of all,
they get sucked up into that world where
that's who you're hanging around with
all the time and there's an extra charge.
You know,
if you're dating some chick and she's
on the cover of sports illustrated like
holy Shit, there's like an extra jolt
to that that people find attractive,
especially people who are in
that whole celebrity world,
especially guys that can get any normal
non-celebrity chick and then like a
celebrity chicken. It's
the same with like, you
know,
hot chicks look at celebrity dudes way
differently than just regular dudes.
That's for damn sure.
I mean routers are saying that 50% while
nearly 50% of a Hollywood marriage or
regular marriages fail that uh,
70% of Hollywood marriage.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
It's the whole idea behind it is,
look, all celebrity is,
is some crazy trick.
You are tricked into thinking
that someone else's special,
especially if it's celebrity,
just force a Labor Day just
for the sake of celebrity.
I mean like actors and stuff like that.
I mean there's actors that you
respect because they're talented,
but it's not like, you know,
like got an author, you know,
like there's a celebrity author,
like someone whose work was really
profoundly affected you, you know,
there's something, there's some sort
of a special connection to that.
It's like you, you have this love for
this guy because of what he's produced.
Like wow,
you produce some amazing stuff.
But there's a lot of people that are
famous just because they got on a show and
then they're just like reading someone's
lines and they're in a movie and
whatever. It's like, that's
a bizarre, bizarre life.
You know, that life doesn't
make any sense. Like your,
you're treated so much better than
the average person. Rose Garden.
Everybody fucking loves, you
know, Rosebud, Rosebud, Rosebud.
My barrier and the Rosebush.
You talking about Orson Welles
citizen Kane talking about
Mel Gibson. Crazy. Fuck.
Oh, what did he say to you in the Rose
Garden? Is that what he saying? Yeah,
but what I'm saying is
that, you know, your,
your whole psychology gets fucking
mangled, you know, you, you know,
that doesn't make any sense.
So the world doesn't make any sense.
You don't have the right,
your character is wrong.
Your character as a human being is
wrong because the amount of energy that
you're getting for the amount of effort
and that you're putting out is all out
of balance.
You know,
like that's one of the reasons
why celebrities go fucking crazy.
It's because they think the world is
crazy. How could the world not be crazy?
If you're kissing my ass and I'm driving
a Bentley and I'm making millions and
people were screaming to
see me everywhere, I go out
there taking photos of me.
That's insane. This world is crazy. Of
course you're going to become crazy too.
But the thing that happens
that I notice is with artists,
especially when they
become like super famous,
there's like a burst or they can hang in
there for a bit to hang in there for a
few years and keep producing and then
ultimately they just get soft and it
dwindles off.
Almost like to a person,
almost to a person once their celebrity
like hits that super peak, you know,
they become big and famous.
They can,
they can hang in there and
produce for a few years,
but then eventually their
creativity just dries up.
I think it's their connection to the
universe dries up. That's what I think.
I think they'd lose
appreciation to for life.
They become a Douche bag and then they
just don't have the connection anymore.
That's why all eyes are on
the Double Rainbow Guy. Right.
Like a couple of months he's gonna be
like food that fucking rainbows. Shit.
Double Rainbow.
There's a,
a clip that Jimmy Kimball
twittered and uh, I,
I watched it and it's
this dude who's seen a rainbow. There's
two rainbows. Yeah, he found it.
He had an MMA fight, seen big fat guy
and he, um, he, everyone's seen what?
Double Rainbow Guy.
He hasn't seen it.
I haven't heard of that
fucking serious dude.
You can't say 3 million hits out of 300
million people in this country alone.
How many in Europe and how many in Asia?
Wow. If you can say everybody. Anyway,
it's fascinating.
This guy just goes crazy when he sees
these rainbows for whatever reason.
Don't do that. That to shit didn't work.
It was just that video. I wasn't, yeah.
Anyway, this a double rainbow
guy. Famous on that. No,
it's on Brian. Brian's. Brian
could play. I think you can.
I just don't know how to do it. Do you
know how to drag this shit into Ustream?
Producer Brian? A year two I think you
actually have to have to video, so, oh,
really? Yeah. All right. Hold on here.
I thought it can show a web page that
you're viewing. All right, here we go.
Okay.
Oh,
oh God.
Look at that
triple rainbow. Oh my God. Oh,
double rainbow all the way across.
He's crying here by the way. He says
it, knocked him over, knocked him down.
You goes.
At one point I started weeping.
The energy from the rainbow knocked
him down. What does this mean?
What does it mean? It means
mushrooms work. What does it mean,
right?
Oh my God.
Probably the best bill I've ever seen.
I know,
but this guy sounds like he's got a bag
of Leprechaun gold in his hand while
Christie Brinkley sucking his dick.
I'm just, yeah, there's just a rainbow,
gigantic Ufo, like a hundred yards
above the surface or something
and they're communicating.
You know what's even better than that is
all the music that has been coming out,
and I was talking to my
friend the other day, if this,
this song is so great that I would
actually buy the single off of iTunes and
that is from some dude
looking at a rainbow.
He explained what song you're talking.
Okay.
There's a couple of these songs
that have come from this video.
[inaudible] song parody is one
that is so good that I would,
I mean that's like, well let's just,
I don't know which one this is.
Let's see what this one is.
Yeah,
well this double rainbow dude.
Oh Wow.
I like this.
Two rooms.
Sounds like one republic.
There's actually another one that
takes a whole different approach.
That's my kind of like Tim and Eric
Snyder. No, no, no. We don't have here.
You don't hear more double rainbow songs.
It kind of like scratching that
double double rainbow. You know?
It's like a whole difference,
but I think that's auto tune.
You can't fuck with that.
You really like on no two songs though.
That drives me nuts.
I do know when brothers do it,
others do it, but you right, the white
guy in a rock band can do election, man.
I like, that's what I like about
Biggie, notorious B I g. His,
it was all about the inflection, the way
he would talk and rhyme and punctuate.
You'd never sang. It doesn't
matter. Really can't sing.
I don't want to, you know,
even when they sing,
if it's auto tune and now really singing,
I like a little Wayne's out 10 stuff.
Yeah, I like it. I still like it. I like,
I can do this.
Definitely being overused by,
I mean there's a lot of music that
uses it nowadays that you know,
most of the time that I think is okay and
it sounds better than hearing Brittany
Spears going like without it,
you know?
Is that what you sounds like
double rainbow guy sounded amazing.
Can you imagine what Britney Spears
could sound like? What? You know,
she's already using it, dude. Yeah.
You could put a lot of shit together
with that for sure. It just,
it just sounds gross to me.
It's missing so much.
I've been really getting
into the black keys lately.
You listen to black keys at all?
Yeah, I downloaded all it. Damn.
They got some good fucking songs,
man.
I listened to them all the way to a
Ontario Improv every, uh, every night.
This weekend when I was doing shows there.
Every time I drove up there,
listen to the black keys. Oh, I'm, this
weekend I'm at, um, before I forget,
cause I forgot to say at the beginning
of the show. That's the ticket.
I'm at the John Lovitz a comedy
club Saturday night. John Love,
who's my friend that I
never talked to and we did
a season of news radio. He's a good dude.
I think he's going to come down. Uh,
I doubt it. I don't think he has
anything to do with that place really.
It just hasn't anything. It's like just
his name. I don't know. Just guessing.
[inaudible] um, put my name
up. Dance. He got us the worst.
James Cagney slash John.
Love it. What was the his,
his character back in the day in Saturday
night live. Who would lie and say,
that's the ticket,
right?
Any impressions I fucking
suck or use your voice.
Get on the horse.
John Wayne,
he's doing an impression of someone
doing an impression of Peter Fonda.
Peter Fonda,
Jimmy [inaudible].
You're talking about doing an
impression was born after 1960.
Uh,
Ari Shaffir go ahead.
No, no, that was terrible. It's terrible.
He's got already down. Good to it, Joe.
Okay. I joked to an Ra joke, oh,
you're like plugging along doing
Jewish women, uh, uh, see this.
This is what I look like.
This is what a Jew looks like.
He's always, that's called a Jew and
wondering what Jewish woman looked like.
Bam. Same thing. Not that good.
Mumble. Mumble. Yeah. The Joey
one. I've got down over decades.
I've only been making fun of Ari.
I can't,
I can't. I wish I could. I
would be doing that. I can't do,
she used to have a real good Mike Tyson,
but I don't anymore.
Tyson's kind of easy, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's,
you know. That's why I never really
liked impressionists because it's,
there's a trick and the trick
is you're like, oh shit.
He sounds just like that guy and
that makes anything extra funny.
It's like it's kind of entertaining.
You put it,
I can put some good material on
top. Doctor Steve Berle. All right.
At least I could a couple of weeks
ago can, I might've lost it. Lost it.
Come on here. Wait, nevermind.
I have to hear it. No, no, no,
not do it at that to Steve Brule. Hey,
you got some vinegar on your driveway?
Just put some vinegar on it. Don't be
stupid. That sounds like Max Eberly. Hey,
you know you might be a
little knee his friend,
but who cares about all that dumb.
They could look at my dangerous,
it sounded like that shit means a
standup comedian on South Pole. He put,
my dad gets on there.
All the girls went to see my dad.
I don't even know who he all, I don't know
who you're talking about. Who's doctor?
Steve Berle back to [inaudible].
John [inaudible]. Riley.
I'm a little bit, then it
sounded a little bit, you guys,
if you went on to be with me, you
gotta come over here. I'm doc,
just put some milk on it. Get some
table kicked please. I'm not too bad.
I kind of an impression.
I kind of understand that
you're doing an impression.
It's not terrible. I'll try harder
next time. I'm rooting for you.
So I'm doing all impressions
though. Like when you see like someone's
act, they do like all impressions.
That drives me fucking nuts.
I don't want to see that.
Especially when like all of them sound
the same and they're only really good at
the really ups like, Oh, this is
pachino. Yeah. You know, it was good.
Really good impressions as Jay Moore.
Holy Shit.
Have you ever heard was calling him his
Collin Quinn is fucking brilliant and
uh, his walking is really good too.
He's got a really good walking.
A lot of duties.
Oh, I got one. I got one impression,
but no one would know it. But um,
there was a German thrash band
and the 80s called Creator.
They're probably still around and they
barely spoken English and I'm not even
gonna do it. It's terrible. That's
terrible. Well, I'm sorry. It's hard to,
I'm going to do harm or do
it. Yeah, go ahead man. Okay.
There's my favorite creators
song was called the pestilence.
They don't know any English, so there's
not too much banter in between songs.
So here it comes.
You just killed.
Why was it so loud? That was the
pestilence. That's all I can do.
Pretty God.
Damn good version of that.
No idea.
That's get it together.
Cock sucker.
The Cock sucker.
You blew my fuck.
I'm smoking a bone with the cat.
Trying to enjoy my off time.
Even Dr Jay could have helped me listen
until a little fucking podcast and now
I've got crackles in my speakers. Cock
sucker. Okay. You know what we could do?
We can do, uh, since Joey's not here with
us, he was supposed to be here with us.
Let's talk about UFC Oakland,
right?
And you give us your
predictions. Joey Karate, UFC,
Oakland jail Sonnen versus Anderson Silva.
The spider.
The spider is in the house and chill.
Son's got a can of raid cock sucker.
Shit's going to get crazy chill.
Sonnen's going to look for that double,
double wide, double leg, whatever.
Look for that fucking takedown.
But the spider's got those knees,
motherfucker.
He comes up with them like Oj Simpson
in that fucking hurts commercial.
Those knees. It's called. It has
gone. I'm, he's going to put up
Carla Ricardo, meda,
Henzel Gracie revenge.
Cocksucker Ricardo are made a student
of the Great Henzel Gracie victim of
Matthews. Matthews. Standup
performance leg kicks,
punches his first TKO standing
in UFC history. But Ricardo,
I made a big dogs not hearing it bro.
Big Dog back his back for
more big dog is gonna fuck.
Start out with an inside leg kick
right to the balls on purpose. Sorry.
Much respect.
He's going to take all the fight out
of the country board is your fucking
country.
Breakfast Cock sucker mad use
with the fucking ground and pound.
He's the godfather of it.
Respect.
Respect to the godfather
around growth is on the card.
Uh, big, big and junior. Dos Santos,
respect that gut.
Big countries come and dropping
bombs on your mom's fuck car alarms.
Big country is the best fat men fighting
in the UFC today. No one even close.
What's his,
what's his name that just knocked up
that just knocked out tight? Todd Duffy.
Mike [inaudible].
Mike Russo is a close second,
but big countries right up in there.
Big country would have done it with the
first punch. That's a difference though.
Don't let that fucking big GI Joe Looking.
Motherfucker beat on you for three rounds.
Land that punch early. Learn respect.
Um, Roy Nelson. Oh, junior dos Santos Sto.
Any motherfucker willing to go outside
with those ears? That's a tough dude.
I do. Doesn't give a fuck.
He's got a mouse living in
his left ear. He feeds him.
It keeps him company in between rounds.
Oh, he's working all fucking squirrel and
his right one. You know what I'm saying?
Junior dos Santos.
Let me tell you something for breezy over
dooms ears are still wiggling from the
last time though. Santo's hit him.
He hit him with that upper cut.
He started tuning into 97
one the ff park station.
Fucking,
he heard a system morning and then alarm
clock started going off in his head.
All right. That's how hard junior
dos Santos hits. Who knows?
It's the fat man against the banger
with a mouse living in his ears.
It's a Goddamn Tarzan movie.
Got His weight and who else?
Oh,
Tiago Alvarez coming up against my man,
John Fitch.
The grinder comes out of the same Johnny
Cash song. God's going to cut you down,
bitch, and we tell some Tiago Alva is
going to try to cut you down to that.
Mother fucker's got glue in his brain.
You hear what I'm saying?
Somebody stuck glue in his
brain and he don't give a fuck.
He wants revenge.
She's a totally different animal
from the first time you guys met.
He wants revenge,
but John Fitch chain here in at John
Fitch at different animal as well.
He's got his black belt from Dave
Camera, Rio, Brazilian Jujitsu.
Go Willa style ready to take them down.
Grind it out.
It's a fucking battle to the finish.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tiago Alvarez leg kicks and John Fitch
with elbows to your fucking head.
I'm getting fired up. Where's my blood
pressure medication? I'm fired up.
Just listen to this.
So beautiful. Oh, that was wonderful.
For those of you that I don't know,
Tony Deals,
we do a um,
an MMA review or UFC review and a preview.
It's called 10th Planet Kush.
Joe Is just the best.
No one can predict fights better
than it's so entertaining.
The most hilarious person I've
ever met in my whole life,
like just for hanging out with
them. Nobody's funnier. I know.
Just a regular basis over everything,
about everything,
about anything he could read. He just
read a book. You can pick up a book.
It would just start reading it and
it'd be funny. I love that guy.
He could talk about anything. You
could have Joey and just, you know,
turn on the news. Here's
Lindsay Lohan. What do you
think? Cause this motherfucker,
somebody did have proper and he would
just go off about Lindsay Lohan and the
jokes and start flowing the other day.
Me and when when you were on stage,
me and Joey
were way too stone and so we were just
sitting in the green room looking at it.
Thanks. And then he's like, I'm gonna have
to start a podcast. And I'm like, what?
And he's like, do you got any other
recorders? And I'm like, all right,
let's do a podcast. So we're
going to, we record a 10 minutes.
We're just gonna like throw these
podcasts anytime we're together.
And it's just called cats and it's
just me and him talking about cash.
That's beautiful man. I tell you about
Captain Samurai, Captain Samurai.
It lives in my back yard.
He's got scratches on his face and he
looks like Bruce Leave from enter the
dragon number when he came out and
the guy hit him with the claw. Yeah,
that's my cat. He's got like nine
cats. Right? Check out the episode.
He actually has nine cats to outside.
Oh, let's tell, tell people how to,
what does it just pull the seventh planet
Kush Kush and go to episode 15 and 16
those are Joey at his best. 15 and
1610 pennant Kush. His name is,
his character has a UFC review characters.
Joey karate,
but his real name is Joey Diaz.
It's fucking priceless. Yeah.
Joey's always with me on the road. I
think he's coming with me Saturday night.
I've got to ask him.
I think he's coming on Saturday night.
It doesn't have anything else booked.
Uh, at the John Lovitz comedy club,
but he did all weekend in Ontario. He's,
he's just the funniest dude. I know.
It's just so fun to hang around with.
He always brings an element of the party,
you know, like whenever we do shows
without Joey, there's still fun as fuck.
But there's something about having Joey
around and just, he, he brings the party,
you know, the party starts
with Joey gets there, you know,
cause he don't give a fuck. Yeah.
He's like the ultimate flavor.
Flave but funny. Yeah. You know. Well
I got funny flavor. Flave you know,
it's just like,
he's just the ultimate hilarious dude.
Do you think the gay people
have flashlights smoothies
where after they're done
with their flashlights to just put a straw
in it and like walk around the house?
It's an out of the hole.
Oh Dude.
Brian,
this we, I'm sure you can just Google it,
I'm sure, but what would it be? Flexible.
There's gotta be some
low out of flashlights.
Google that. All video.
Now, what's the latest?
What's the latest with the real doll
pipe technology. They hit a wall.
They hit a wall.
They hit a wall apparently according
to Chris to do to worse at flashlight.
The Vagina in the real doll is hard and
not comfortable. It doesn't feel good.
Does it feel like the flashlight?
Listen man,
I don't need to be fucking some
rubber doll. I know it's not a person.
I'm not pretending.
Okay.
A fleshlight to me is perfect just and
it doesn't have to look like a vagina
either. Stop. Just make it a whole.
All right, so I don't feel it.
That's making it a hole. Did I stick
my dick in and I shoot a load into,
I don't need to fuck some fake doll and
do it doggy style and put her hands on
my balls and shit. I don't need
that. That's just gross. To me.
That's even more gross.
It's like you're pretending it's a person.
I'm not pretending it's a person. I'm just
trying to shoot a load here. All right.
Pretending it's a person. There's just
something about a fleshlight that's like,
that you put on like a head,
like, like a one of those helmets.
Like helmet you see like a dick,
but it's not yours.
Obviously you see it and whatever
that girl in that virtual
reality world,
like she's suck like that flashlight
that you to have it like moves on the
inside. It's like controlling. And
if you'd like a mouth, it grabs your,
you know what I mean? It's the exact same
stroke, Ej, you know, if it's going up,
how cool would that be?
I would use that shit program would
pay like 900 bucks for that. Yeah.
What helmets x, like Dan and they
had a code and that code would,
would transmit to the, uh, the fleshlight
say if you add, uh, each video,
each video was coded,
you know,
so you would take someone and they
would figure out how to program into the
computer so that the,
the,
the hands or whatever the fuck
mechanical thing that you would have that
controls to the movement on the fleshlight
would move in conjunction with what's
on the screen. It would be like
a, uh, a basic computer pro.
So like if you're out of town, your
wife could send, make a video for you.
She could send it,
you plug it in.
Then how did someone
interpret what she's doing?
She can make a video me
jerking off another dude.
What the fuck are we have to
be? You turn off you? Yeah.
Yeah.
You would ever have to be,
could it be live or you'd
have to be really open minded
guy so I could see and I'll just jerk
off and them it's way better than just
porn. Yeah. Some to do that.
Some something's ready guys.
Why don't you guys fuck their
wives? Have you seen idiocracy? No,
I keep hearing about it.
No, I haven't done so much.
It's so much shit that people said that.
Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people. Oh dude,
it's so, but it's good.
It's by Mike Judge.
But that's not an idea
that is uniquely mine.
The idea that people are getting dumber.
I think anybody,
everybody who's paying attention
thinks that people are getting dumber.
Like a lot of people getting smarter,
but a lot more getting dumber, you know?
And this is not just like,
you know, when I was a kid,
people were smarter and
all that grandpa bullshit.
There was a fact that I read on
the Internet that the average kid,
high school kid in 1960 had 200 more
words in their vocabulary than the average
kid in 2010 what was the first year?
1960 yeah. I don't know if it's true.
What about the new words that are add?
Like with Ebonics and all that
stuff and I'll slang words.
There's a lot of new shit.
Yeah. Do those count though?
They're not in the dictionary.
They don't count how the dictionary,
how popular to something I have to
be before it gets in there. No, no,
because I know there's a lot of words
that you would think would be in there by
now. You know? Quick. How about getting
knuckles and with the explosion?
Remember Joey, I thought Joey was the
only one doing it. Did I make that up? No,
I thought he made it, but then
everyone started those things.
It was like six years ago
I bought Zoe made it up.
What if he did and he just didn't know it?
I don't think so because now you
see it in movies all the time.
Everybody's doing it. I hate doing it
now because it feels sent don. Yeah,
I do it when we get off. If I do it
all the time before it was popular.
Yeah. We do that all the time.
We get on stage, but you know,
I feel like one part of me says that,
yeah,
don't do it because everybody else
is doing and then the party, he says,
who's who gives a fuck spending
the shaking hands. Hey,
but I do it backwards. Now.
If you start with the explosion
and then you go tuned to the fist,
that's two creative. You're
trying too hard. It's better.
That's the editor in Saudi. It doesn't
make sense to me to make sense to me.
I want to touch them out
goals and then there's an
explosion. Hey, what's up? Boom.
Hey, what's up? Boom. You're not
going to sell that. That's not,
that's how that could work, ma'am. You've
got 2000 people on the want to do it.
If you want to do it, go right
ahead, but I think you're,
what if I do it to you and you do it the
other way? I think you're out of line.
I think you need to abandon this. I
like the faggy. What do you got like
I like to do that one. I
like that one. No problem.
No problem with dudes. Squish my
fingers. When dude shake your hand.
Shake your hand.
I want to touch the finger tip thing
where they go around the fingertip and
cross your fingers like what?
Are you
nervous? Do you think that? I don't
know what it is they're doing,
but if I grab someone's hand
and it's like they got it wrong,
I let let up and try to like rejects it,
let's fix you don't like
that nervous hand Jews.
I'm really getting paranoid
about people's hands and stuff.
Like our friend went to the
apple store the other day,
they totally saved his life and he was
just talking about how these guys are
just life like his hard
drive crashed and they,
the guy who just went right on right
on that on the computer and he was just
saying like how he was doing it
and how gross his keyboard was,
but the guy did not even
flinch and touched it and I
was thinking how many apple
employees like girlfriends get pregnant
from really bad fingering because they
might,
their hands must be like pregnant.
You know how much fucking calm
has to be on all those girls.
Fucking fingers can't survive.
My keyboard has so much shit on it.
He said he didn't believe it.
That's obviously don't think
anyone's getting pregnant,
but you know how much comments on your
hands after you work at an apple store.
How about none? No one's coming
in their keyboard. Brian. Ah,
you don't ever masturbated.
He never masturbating and wiped it on a
towel and you still had a little bit of
come around the corner and you fucking
start typing your bit to income. Dude,
you don't let it go to waste to what
this show has gone down hill hard.
We're talking about fingering loads.
Brian,
you hijack this goddamn shirt you hijack
to show with this crazy story about
getting people pregnant from
touching keyboards on a banana.
You're only out of banana.
Oh,
Brian is on this crazy fucking diet where
he's trying to lose 35 pounds and he
won't shave until he loses the weight.
So he's got this Muslim beard.
He's rocking right now and he still
has how many pounds ago? Oh, well,
I'm down 19 pounds since June 18th
and the way he's doing it is obviously
unhealthy. It's rotting and well, you're
the ones that can be a protein bar.
I forgot though.
How crazy is it?
Just by 19 pounds. All the hot
chicks that are just bombing you.
I think that's amazing man.
Just like just like that.
You've got all these girls all over. You
got this last one when he was fat? Yeah,
I know. And now he's got dude, it's
incredible. I, you know what props bro,
you gotta I've never seen.
What do you attribute your
attractive institute? Brian,
do you believe it's your sense of humor?
I still suck my thumb still.
My get big by their own.
Their own.
I like that.
Brian is like the oldest
child I've ever met
my life.
You really,
he reminds me of like friends that
I had when I was in eighth grade.
Like never grow up. You always stay
with you when you got molested.
What eighth grade
fuck are you laughing at?
So that's wrong.
What do you think chicks dig in you if
you had to guess that real personality.
Definitely.
I am like real person and I opened
doors for him and stuff like that.
Good cleanup. God come in after the
Douche bags. Right, right, right.
And maybe I think guy,
I think you're amazing success lately.
It's only been on the last like a
month where it's been incredible.
I think it's because chicks like
cats, you love cats. Seriously.
Think about that. Think about the cat
thing. I don't think that's it though.
Because actually most of the chicks,
I hate cats.
Once you date one pretty girl that all
of a sudden other girls can smell it.
What is your name? He realized it. Look,
see you out with a pretty girl and
like look at this bad motherfucker.
I want him now. How did
he get her? I think that,
I think a lot of it and this city is
just people fucking like taking care of
girls because like I know so many girls
that I talked to their boyfriends or
like, you know, fucking freaking
out about all of garden.
Like you know like can you pay
this? Can you, you know, like they,
they don't get taken on dates,
you know,
they don't get treated like how they
want to be treated out here because
everyone's trying to survive out here.
Girl, I saw you with last
week. I swear to God,
I swear to God I didn't see what that
would have thought she was Jessica Alba.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm like,
what the fuck is going
on with Brian Vegas?
Like I'm seriously thinking about
getting a cat. I'm not even kidding.
I'm not even kidding. Strong words
cause Eddie doesn't even like cats.
I like cats.
I,
my new one's pretty sweet man.
The grind of fucking relationships.
Finding someone,
Brian,
you're single man right now was I feel
like it was fucking great. Doesn't it?
Until you clean out your iPhone
of old pictures and you're like,
oh Luca doesn't his kits. I need an I
break up for apple. Once you break up,
if the text by face your ex girlfriend
and it destroys everything or puts it in,
we'll go back together next week.
She goes to Jews. I break up,
they got time machine
time machine and I break up and go back
breakup. We were only taking a break.
We were breaking up right
now easier.
There's easy it is to
just flip them at the,
which the craziness argument you've
gotten a chick with recently, recently,
recently over the last 10 years
of your life? 10 years craziest.
I'll just give him some room so the girls
don't know he's talking about them. Uh,
last,
I know you've had some doozies getting,
got some doozies getting a tattoo behind
my ear of a heart or something like
that. Yeah. This one girl I dated,
she wanted within the third week she to,
I get matching tattoos behind
her ears and I'm like already,
we've only been dating for three weeks.
And she goes, she goes, if you've got me.
And I'm like, wow. Was like,
okay, that sounds good.
Cause I was thinking I'll just get it
lasered off, you know, whatever happens.
But like we were really
close to actually doing that.
How much do you regret not doing?
Wow. Huh? Do you know? I uh,
I don't think I would ever do it.
I think if help is actually on
the way to the Tattoo Studio,
I would have just like chloroform or
something like that in terms of that.
But what if you know you were in the
moment and she went first and you're
getting and you had a couple of Japanese
is spoken a little sign on top of doing
it. I could see you doing it. Laughing
about it. I tell you we do that.
That's so crazy.
No,
she wanted a mark.
You see so many women when you
get involved in relationships,
we want to make sure that you're for real.
Yeah. You want to make sure you're like
a test for real. You in it for real.
Are you in it for real?
For Real? Yeah. How about,
I was talking about this
on my message board today.
How about dudes who fucking share
a Facebook page with their wife?
Some fucking guy sent me a message.
You know it's like Bob and Jennifer
Mckella Han and I'm like, what?
You share a Facebook page with a chick?
I have this ex girlfriend that I love.
She's a great person to
talk to and stuff by.
Her fucking husband is addicted to
Farmville. So like all day long,
it's Farmville, this mafia
wars, this. And I'm just like,
I'm like texting her or
sending her a message, like,
would you fucking stop like telling me
how much oranges you have and stuff like,
and go, okay, this is somebody,
I'm sorry this is so and so's
boyfriend or husband. Uh, she,
do you want to talk to her?
And I'm like, no, I can't.
You just have your separate fucking
Farmville account and just get out of her.
I'm so confused. The farm each other's
messages on Facebook like, hey,
someone's Heather or fuck.
So it's so, so and so. You're
the worst. What? Dunkin?
Yeah. So, so, and so, uh, just got
a brand new horse in their stable,
you know, like a teller. So every
time you play this game at updates,
your Facebook updates your Facebook
automatically. Oh my God, that's so good.
And they share inboxes
together. It's like, dude, you
don't have any life anywhere.
I can't. What if I just wanted to send,
Oh, you look cute in that one picture.
He goes, dude sent me anything, an email
message on Facebook and the message was
he came to the Ontario show and he said,
I saw your show.
Did you ever consider the possibility
that Jesus was real and that he was who he
says he was and I automatically
dismissed him? I'm like, first of all,
it's a silly question and second of all,
how can I debate a guy who's got a
fucking Facebook page with his wife? Like,
you're on your own dude.
Good luck. Have a good time.
But we can't have any conversations.
I can't have a serious conversation
about anything. I mean,
even if you're like goddamn scholar
and you know and you know and you're,
you're a brilliant person and knows a lot
about the history of the, you know, the,
the I, the origins of Jesus. I
can't talk to you about that.
You got to fucking Facebook page with the
chick, dude. Does that drive you nuts?
Give a call girl or a dude rather.
And his girlfriend answers the phone.
What the fuck
is that? Oh, what is that?
That's the guy trying to prove his love.
Yeah.
My password to my Facebook, I
swear I call it, you know what,
that's probably like getting
back together type shit.
Girl breaks up with guy and they're
like, I'll do anything. I'll do anything.
Cause at that point you got,
you'll do anything.
How about giving your fucking
password, your Facebook,
your Twitter, all that shit.
Let me check out them direct messages.
That's probably what it is.
I called Opie opie and Anthony is chicken.
Answer the phone.
A whole call the cell phone.
Who is assistant? Hey,
maybe told her. Answer it. You know,
especially if you don't know who the
fuck it is. You know, you see some,
you know phone number and you're not
even sure who the hell it is. Maybe.
Maybe he didn't give you the whole phone.
Maybe that was a whole phone.
Maybe that's why she was saying maybe
that was a ho or maybe that wasn't the
whole phone because you're not a Ho and
so he doesn't care who answers the real
phone, you know? Oh I see. I
don't think he rocks it like
that. He just had a kid to
Eddie Bravo.
Someday you're going to have kids.
What are you thinking about that you
feel extra pressure even thinking about
that, considering how fucked
up your childhood was?
I did growing up,
I really thought that hey,
there might be a chance that I don't
give a fuck about my kids because my dad
didn't get by me. I mean
I'm the, I was like scared.
Like that would kill me if
my father thought or if my
child thought of me like I
thought of it. Think of my father
that would fucking destroy me.
Saw that I was scared of having kids
most of my life, but I almost had a kid.
I thought I had a kid then,
you know, we had the DNA test,
but I had a kid for three months.
I played the daddy and that's when
I knew I could, I could, I could,
I would love my kid no matter what.
That was a test.
I thought I had a kid for three months.
What was it like when you walked away?
After three months?
I didn't walk away.
After three months I stayed after
we found out it wasn't mine.
I stayed and I hung in there as long
as possible, but the chick was just so,
uh,
um,
uh, she just, it just
do not fucking work, man.
You know how that goes. Yeah.
And I had to make a choice.
You know what the craziest thing is
when we finally did break up, I'd come,
I came back like a maybe two
months later to see Jake and he,
he still remembered me is to remember,
but it was kind of like,
fuck where you been for two months.
And then I came back like six months
later and when I came back and he really
did recognize me, like the girl had a
pullout, like pictures of us at the zoo.
Remember? He's the one who took you
to the zoo, remember? And he's like,
Dallas, like a fuck. You
don't even know me. God Damn,
those motherfuckers won't forget you
if you're not around for like six months.
Has the mood. Yeah. Then
I realized, you know,
once he started forgetting me,
then I realized, you know what?
I could just step away from this.
Now. It'd be a good idea just to,
just to get out of this.
He doesn't remember miss six months
off from seeing a baby. Yeah.
Yeah man. He was like, it
was like this happened when
was like one, one and a half,
something like that is walking around,
you know?
And then he just started
forgetting about me.
There was a trip and
then I just backed out.
How many times have you thought a
chick was pregnant and wasn't? Dude,
I didn't want to talk about that.
How much does not even talk about
crazy shit like that man. Ugly.
Yeah. We should also say we're going
to be on another podcast. Oh yeah,
we're going to do Doug Benson as
podcasts and were like two hours.
We got a dirt through traffic and,
well it's five now.
We're all right.
And we got to hit down to the UCB to do
the Doug Benson podcasts tonight. Crazy.
We hung out with Doug when we were in
Vegas. He was there for some poker.
And so what he came to show it the house
of Blues and we hung out and then we,
he came to the UFC the next day too.
He's a good motherfucker and he's the
reason why I had to make a fan line cause
I fucked up and twittered my
number, my number, I thought to him,
I thought it was twittering it direct
message. Right. It was a repliers.
I've twittered just a straight
message to the whole fucking world.
So I had to get a new phone.
But you gotta do son.
But so we're going to go do the Doug
Benson podcasts right after this.
Anything else we should talk about before
we wrap this pitch up? Any problem?
I'm good. Join all of our twitters,
which are low listed below Eddie Bravo.
It red band Joe Rogan.
No, I don't. They know.
I don't want anybody to jump on my
Twitter. My Shit. I just post disgusting,
crazy weird ass shit. You do
not want to see my shit. It's,
it's definitely already psychology. Plus
you want to keep it, you want to keep it.
That's how I look at it. I like, I
want to, a VIP could easily offended,
do not follow me,
please.
Well, no one who's listening to this show
is easily offended unless you're just
looking for ammunition. That mother
Fucker, what'd he say about Jesus?
There's a lot of people out
there doing that. I'm sure
we should also say that
you have a new Q and a, uh,
oh yeah. You know, I haven't
really set that up totally.
I mean, I signed up for it,
but I don't know how to do it in the,
in the future we'll have
like a Q and a podcasts.
I should do them by myself or I just read
off the questions and just answer them
and just do it to camera.
So I'll do one of those in the future
because I get so many of the same
questions over and over again.
It would be better if I could figure out
a way to answer him just to, you know.
But if you want to find out info on
comedy dates, go to Joe rogan.net.
Um, my Twitter is just Joe Rogan. Of
course Eddie's Twitter is Eddie Bravo.
Brian is red ban
on the 10th planet J j.com
get on my forum if you want,
you know for future seminar dates that
all up on the forum man. light.com too.
Yeah, we are sponsored by
fleshlight.com and uh, like I said,
even if I wasn't sponsored by it,
I probably wouldn't talk about it as much,
but it's still telling you you should
go fuck one of those things cause it's
awesome. I think different sizes. I
don't know they have a mouth though.
I saw a mouth online.
The things really
and twilight, when did they have a
twilight one can fly. It's got banks.
It's a vampire one night. Twilight
one now. Fucking vampire cock sucker.
Let me tell you something. When I
was young, the bottom Ms. Collins.
That's a fucking vampire. Okay. He
walks in the room. Ladies and gentlemen,
you guys
have been a of,
I don't know what you've been,
you might be fucking screaming upset
at. He's at me right now. Who Know?
Fuck knows what you are. You know, I can't
say you've been anything. You guys, uh,
you're just out there, but we
appreciate you. You might be cool.
Hopefully you are. Hopefully you've
been great. As you're watching,
you haven't been yelling. You forget
to talk about some other shit, but, uh,
we appreciate the fuck out of it as always
on our podcast by lays also. Now on,
I caught again a stitcher. Oh yeah,
it's on stitcher. So what stitcher is,
is a, um, if you go to Joe
rogan.net, um, the front page,
there's a link and if
you click on the link,
it'll take you to the stitcher website
that's set up just for my podcast and it
gives you the information exactly how
to do it, but it's real, super simple.
You load it up on your phone pretty much.
Now you could stream
over your cell phones,
you can stream our podcasts and
it's, it's, we're also on iTunes.
But this is just another
thing you can not,
it's for people who are not
into apple and you know,
they want to be able to
do it on their smartphone,
but we're also going to be
switching over. So we, we have a,
a Zune one and, uh, we'll have an
iPhone app one, two, that'll all be,
that's all in the works. So, uh,
thank you very much for tuning in,
and we will see you bitches next week.
And I say bitches with all the love
in the world as Salaam Alaikum.